Experience.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the post UFC wrap
up show with Tony Hinchcliffe.
Hey everybody and be your host Joe Rogan.
We are on a flight right now.
I'm coming back from Dallas, Texas. Sorry,
I sound like just kicked that lady chair.
Um,
where we had a great old time at uh,
the Verizon wireless theater
on Friday night and uh,
and then the UFC last night and now we're
headed back. Shout out to Brian Doobie.
Had Breakfast with,
turned out to be all right.
Turned out to be an interesting guy.
I was a little worried about him at first.
Came in strong with a future.
Many questions. You get
interrupted a little bit,
but turned out to be a very good
dude. Um, but you never know man.
You know, meet some strange dude. Have
Breakfast with them. Can Be Rough,
but you turned out to be very
cool. I think I snapped at
him. No, I was like, what?
Is this a questionnaire, bro. Relax.
Nervous.
He's a good dude. He
just, oh, thank you ma'am.
The young ladies bringing us the towels.
Thank you.
She's got a crazy accent and a,
I don't ever think like this,
but Tony was wondering what she would
sound like if she was having sex.
Uh, yeah. Anyway, so, uh,
we're on the flight back.
We got to give up my
little wet towel and uh,
do you like to caress the towel?
Hold onto it for a little bit.
I like it.
I like to feel like it cold
still hot and she took it back.
What does it, what does that
four to refresh you on the I do.
Would it make you know that you're not in,
you're not in business class or coach?
Yeah, business costs. They just
give you a piece of toilet paper.
His class, they, they treat
you almost as good, don't they?
How does that work? You haven't flown
business class in such a long time.
You don't remember what it's like?
I flew coach just a month ago.
That's one thing,
like if you can afford it,
it doesn't seem like it would be worth it.
But what's worth it is you don't
have to think about it as much.
You have more space, you can relax. Get
off quicker. You get on quicker. Yeah,
but people don't like it. It's
weird, like people like southwest,
I feel like it's an egalitarian airline.
If you get on southwest and
you know everybody's the same.
Yeah.
I'm not into that at all
bad. It's effective. It gets people
on board and not too much bullshit.
I think it's a good system and you can
occasionally get lucky to sit next to
some front people.
I met a girl over the weekend that
works for southwest and she's all like,
she's like, hey, you know, you
must travel a lot if you ever want,
I can get you a discount on southwest
flights. I'm like, Eh, I'm okay.
Sometimes you have to take them though.
Jeb Blues are good airline.
That jet blue that we flew from
buffalo to New York City. Jetblue.
Jetblue is nice.
Yeah.
I feel like it's just,
there's a thing going on where they just
decided to shove as many people into a
plain as possible.
Forget about how good the experiences,
but what if you worked for an airline?
I would,
I'd have to imagine working for jet
blue feels better than working for.
So like,
like United right now and everybody hates
United after that dude got beat up and
dragged off a plane.
Oh it must be such a bummer.
I mean I've had like flight attendants
have to deal with all sorts of mean
people that are snapping at
them cause that guy got beat up.
Right? Like Megan reverse threats
like oh what are you going to do?
Drag me off the here. Yeah. Yeah. Oh for
sure. I just offered you a bag of peanuts.
Ah Yeah,
for sure. Right? Like what
a terrible thing to see.
We decided he's already sitting down,
he's already about to fly.
I mean and they say nope,
you got to get up.
And what's really weird is that
like one dude made that decision.
He's just a security guy
probably for the airport.
Probably not specifically for you
tonight. And he's just like, he's like,
he had it with that Asian surgeon
doctor guys like you know what,
if too much of an attitude for an Asian
Guy, I'm going to drag you out of here.
Cause that what happened?
I don't know. Like,
I mean I don't know if it had anything
to do with the Asian guy part,
but it felt like it,
I think
the story was that they had some
important United employees that had to be
somewhere like that day.
They had to be that somewhere
for some sort of a meeting.
And so in their company,
their ideas that these
people take priority over the
customer to the point where
they like physically removed
or customer and beat him up.
I mean the way they grab that guy and
he's screaming like that is crazy for
someone who's done nothing. Yeah. And
all that guy did was be a customer.
And that's like one of the most
devastating things you could ever watch if
you're like,
uh,
one of the people that's
in charge of publicity for
their company, you'd be like,
what the fuck did you guys
do? Yeah, I think, oh my God.
And you beat that guy up and dragged him
off the plane so an employee can steal
his seat.
You're inconveniencing him.
You saying you're not as
important as our employees.
Our employees are more
important than you like.
That's so crazy that that's their policy
and good for it to be a doctor like that.
It's crazy too.
Hmm? Is that what it was? It was a dark
during. Yeah, it was a doctor
or dentist or something,
but he had patients the next day
and he's like, I have appointments.
I can't miss this flight.
Patients need me.
Man. That's so crazy. That's
so crazy. It's just so sad.
It's so sad.
Especially since he paid for it.
That's a really controversial stuff.
Right?
So if you like think of the morale and
the way it feels to be on that airplane
versus the way it feels to be on like a
jet blue. You get those nice big seats.
Little Tvs behind the seats. Sound
bad at all. Right, so a good ride.
It's like just enough space. Like
maybe not if you're a big giant person.
Don't feel like a dude.
My size is just an space.
Have you had you met my buddy Justin,
Justin Collet and Vegas? Yeah,
the giant. Yeah. He's a legit giant. It
was like seven feet tall. Huge. Yeah.
That guy. He can't even sit on
JetBlue without being [inaudible].
But those are the outliers,
you know.
Does that blue does
the a flat bed that Oh,
do there?
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Jet Blue is a solid notch up.
Joey Diaz,
the big jet blue fan was the jet blue
air airplane commercial we're doing here.
It's not what we were trying to do.
We're on virgin right now,
which is my favorite.
They just got bought by Alaska.
So it might be Jeff, please.
I wonder what's going to happen.
What do I give a fuck? That's true.
This is early morning nonsense.
Talk with Joe and Tony.
I thought you guys were going to
talk about the fights. We will. God,
we will warm it up. So, um, before fight,
when do you think that you want to end?
You will go on your first date.
I think it's going to be really soon.
Is My theory as you saw in this fight
and she defended her championship last
night. Uh, she's very into
me. She kept looking at me.
Dude, she did keep looking at you between
every round. She made a point to like,
you know, like I sorta felt
like our backup corner man,
she looked over at you pointed to you
had started talking to you at one point.
Yeah. That was like,
this is crazy. I know.
Even show in DC and at one point like
what the hell and she's guys thing
pointing at Tony and talking to him.
Yeah, it's hilarious. And like, um,
you know,
we inspire each other.
Like she was looking at me and I'm
like clapping. I'm looking at her like
that's so crazy.
And then she was doing some sort of an
interview before the fight and she said
something and people were laughing
and they were joking around about it.
She was maybe Joe Dogan and
Tony Hinchcliffe would take
me on the road with them.
She's so funny.
She could
be, she could do anything
she wants the way she works.
She's already funny. Two
cheese, she's up bad woman.
She gave her opponent a piece of cloth
cut out to look like a belt that just
said fantasy across the way.
So she probably did that herself in
the bathroom and shit at the hotel.
I've making her fantasy, Beth,
this is all you get, bitch.
This is as close in j a piece of cloth,
but man,
that girl that she fought,
Jessica Andraj blood a tank. Yeah.
That woman has a tank.
It's interesting, man though.
The women in that weight class,
they're all very tough and they always
put up a fight up until the rounds go on.
She just doesn't get any
more tired than she does.
You know what I mean?
Like she does,
but she doesn't show it in this
chick's I'll start to wear down.
You could see the slightest evidence of
it in the last round and she was slowing
down a little bit, but still,
always on our feet. Still
moving. Yeah. Both of them,
man. They're both in phenomenal
shape because you got to
give it up to and drive.
She took a fucking beating man.
Beating and kept coming forward.
Yeah. A lot of friends lake
kicks, she absorbed as with her,
that'll you go on up Polish Iron Lake.
She had us switch your stance a couple
of times to switch back and forth.
She's getting that leg chewed up.
She got tagged with some good
shots including a few head kits.
Yeah, a lot. I had kids three,
five and 10 is like this big
snappy had ones in the front.
Snap kick to the chest. That
shoe looks, it makes me cringe.
That would hurt anybody.
Yes. It was a really interesting
combination. Oh Jesus.
This is now you get to understand
why Tony was attracted to her voice
but it was a perfect combination of
like a ruthlessly powerful attacking
determined person versus like a person
who maybe doesn't have as much physical
power or maybe doesn't have
as much pop on their shots.
But it is a brilliant tactician.
We have brilliant technician.
Like her technique is so good. Man
of footwork is so good. She pops out,
jab out the way she like,
she like slips that leg kick in slack.
You know like she's so
high level man and I'm,
I kept trying to corner her
and she's like, no, not today.
No, we're not stand put.
We're not standing in front of you.
She never really stood in front of her.
She kept moving.
She kept doing a lot of
like just one punches.
I noticed Yolanda was in the first few
rounds a little bit different than the
multiple combinations that I usually see
her throat and I was going to yell like
combinations, but then I'm
like, what the hell do I know?
Then I just started yelling,
set it up, set it up. Yolana
you know what's interesting man?
The real high level kickboxing like
a world championship Moitai and Bella
Beltour and glory and all those like
high level kickboxing events you see on
television.
It's all three minute rounds and what
she's doing is she's kickboxing like
massive foot work, but she's also
fighting off takedown defense,
which makes you more tired and
she's adding another two minutes.
It's really interesting.
Well, I mean if I shoot you at
least all the fights that I've seen,
which is the last four or five,
whatever UFC fights. If we took,
if we made a compile nation of her
getting taken down, Yolanda young j check,
she pops right back up.
Yeah.
Every single time against
get Dalia against Valerie.
The turnout again, everyone
she has, she refuses.
Absolutely refuses to stay down.
Yeah,
she's here mentality that my old wrestling
coach I know wishes I had all the
times he yelled at me
and it's hard because there's
a big muscular person.
I knew her back but she
just like sees through it.
She just looks at a one step at a time.
You can almost see she was lance her foot,
she posts up and she stands up.
It's like she doesn't even
look at it like a challenge.
She's also a superior athlete and a
big part of her athleticism and in a
kickboxing is her legs. She's a big
part of it is her ability to move,
which is like a lot of plyometric type
activities and also her ability to throw
power like in our leg kicks and
your knees and stuff like that.
So her base and her legs are really
strong and when you take her down,
she's so technical, they're more
tired that she becomes that technical.
I'm sure where they're grappling too.
So she's doing the right things
and she's got a lot of power,
a lot of physical power with her legs.
She's explosive and fast or balances sick.
Very, very hard to take down. And if
you get her down, good luck. Keep it a,
now she's a little cat. Yeah,
she's really interesting man.
And she was in full control when the,
the what seeming to be the, you know, um,
oh my God, I forget her name, but she,
despite last name Jessica and Drudge,
drudge, when androgyny put her
against the fence, she would spin,
she would put her against
the fence almost immediately.
Just like she didn't want to end judge
to think that she had control at all for
a second. Yeah, she did it. It
turns out she didn't have control.
It was really interesting because
she was always dangerous though.
Even though she had control of entourage
on drivers, still winging bombs at her,
like any one of those could shut the
lights out. That curl was so tough, man.
I'm so impressed. Yeah, I mean, I'm super
impressed with Yolanda because I mean,
she's so skillful or
movement was beautiful.
And the fact that she was able to do
that for 25 minutes against a marauding
challenge or like that that
girl just kept coming forward. Man,
she tagger kept coming forward.
Kicker keep coming forward. I mean, yeah,
it's really hard for women to knock
out other women in that weight class
especially.
Right.
But I think that it would be beneficial
to some of these women if Yolanda was
just a little bit stronger
to knock them out.
I think taking 300 of those have have,
have,
have like little demon
stone hands to the face.
Like
I me, I said, who's doing
commentary? He goes,
she should have gone to jail for
what she did to Carla Esparza.
She should have gone to jail. And he was
laughing at me saying he's a funny dude.
Man is for me a is fun and he's so
comfortable now. It's really interesting.
He so loose cause trash talk is better.
Like he's a different person.
I've never heard you guys both
on there at the same time.
Are you guys both covering the like the,
like what's happened?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. All of it. And is
that weird for you to have solid. Great.
Love it. Yeah. Yeah,
it's awesome man. It's,
I like doing it with him and I'd like
doing it with Dominick Cruz too and I want
to do it Brian Stann. Um, but man, it's
fun. It's like doing it with a friend.
It's like, you know, and plus you're
both enjoying the fights together.
Like there was one point tried to,
Daniel Cormier is a fun guy, man.
He's really fun.
Like he says funny shit and he'll look
over me in the middle of the fight,
like a crazy fight. You're like,
slap me on the arm, go God tail and,
and he'll like Mauldin sometimes like
he'll like share a moment with you.
Like where he's looking at this like,
are you seeing what I'm seeing?
Like Holy Shit,
you know,
and cause there's a hi,
how you doing? I just,
I just ate. I just ate. Yeah,
we just, we bold just hate.
Right before we got on board.
I'll just like a water please.
Yeah.
Actually I have a coffee as well.
Just cream please. Thank you. Um, but two,
he's really funny, man. Like super funny
and like real friendly. It's like a,
it's real weird how people
don't see him that way.
Like in the public eye and I think he's
been like a little stiff in some press
conferences. But this recent one that
he did with Jon Jones, it was hilarious.
You hear what he said to him, which he
goes, he goes, he goes, John, he goes,
I don't even know if his fights going to
take place if you don't get in trouble
for steroids but doing cocaine.
I sandblasted a prostitute,
dude, dude, he was hilarious.
Does that even mean?
But he was hilarious cause talking
over John. John was frustrated.
He was laughing,
he was all jovial.
It's like he's found the fun in this man.
Yeah,
DC's found the fun in it was
really interesting. He's so great.
That's another one. And
he's like, I mean him,
the Diaz brothers and Yolanda
and I like really my, yeah,
DC is really, really, really
been growing on me especially.
Um,
I mean it's like just so many people
at him count it out against rumble.
Even in the second fight, which he won
the first one and still people are like,
no way he's going to get his
head knocked off and yeah man,
you want to talk about being in there
with someone dangerous like you can hear
and feel the wind to blow by
you and humbleness is a punch.
Like it causes a fucking a tornado in
Japan somewhere when rumble and this is a
punch here in Vegas,
like that's shit are raising,
but don't you think in that fight the
rumble was Kinda done with fighting?
I think people said that looking
back, I, I think he was trying,
I think it's sort of a cop out way to
look like you didn't lose twice to core me
by saying I was going to
retire anyway. It's like, dude,
if you're going to go out like that,
then maybe retire before the fight.
No, I think he wanted to just, first
of all, I'm sure he wanted the money.
It was real good money. Yeah. I think
you wanted to give it one more try,
but I think that as good as rumble is,
and I think he's physically one of
the most talented guys of all time,
if you don't want to do it,
you shouldn't be doing it and clearly
if you're retired afterwards is cause he
didn't want to do it.
This doesn't take anything away from
his ability or who he is or it should in
any way be thought of as an insult.
It's a decision that he's made a personal
decision in life and it's his decision
to make and it's just put, when you make
that decision, it changes who you are.
It's not a bad thing,
but it does change who you are.
There's guys that like
they're their focus,
they're like a Max Holloway Focus and
goal right now is being a champion focus
and goal right now is being,
but he's not thinking whether or not
it shouldn't be fighting anymore.
Like he's not thinking that way
and it's a personal decision.
One day he's going to think that way
and when he does he'll step away to just
like rumbled it.
But he probably had already decided
in his head who's going to step away.
Do you think he would have
stepped away had he won that?
He might've, yeah, he might've.
He might've just decided
to go out with the belt.
Look, he's been in a long time, so a lot
of hard fights, hard training sessions.
He said it himself, I don't want
to get punched in the head anymore.
I don't want to wrestle the dudes anymore.
And I get it, man. It's like, you know,
as talented as he is, he has to do what
he wants to do. That's what a man does.
That's what a human does.
If you want to be happy and fulfilled,
you can't do something just
because you're successful at it.
And so he just didn't
want to do it anymore.
And I think it's should be
applauded that he had the, the, the,
the sense of self to do that and that he
could thank you very much because dude,
he's one of the top contenders.
I'll take some half and half please.
Thank you very much.
So like I, you know, I mean Daniel,
Daniel beat him up both
times, but I feel like, uh,
the second time I was just so surprised
that he was clenching with Daniel.
I was like,
this is crazy.
Yeah.
I guess that's sort of
see the entire thank you.
Maybe he wanted to go out with a bang
and try to take Daniel down, you know,
which would it be crazy.
Yeah, but either way, man,
the dude had an awesome career.
He's had crazy highlight reel
kaos that will be his forever.
You know, like what he did to over
to Sherra what he did to Minotauro.
Nogueira yeah. Ryan Bader.
I mean, come on son,
rumble Johnson put the heat
on people like no other
watching them Gustafson cry in Sweden,
like flying all the way to the other
side of the world to watch a guy cry in
front of his own people. Like,
because some monster came and eat it.
But you know what that just goes to show
you that in life sometimes you've got
to do what you want to do regardless
of what everybody else thinks.
Because here's this guy who's,
if not number one number two
right behind the champ, right?
So you got DC, he's either number one or
John Jones is and they've never fought.
So we don't know. But if, if, if
rumble and Jon Jones did fight,
then we would know if rumbles number two
of reason number one in terms of like
the the biggest challenge to call me yet,
but you know,
he's got to do what he's got to do. If
the cool thing about, you know, like life,
you make decisions like you
don't say to a guy, hey man,
I'll keep me on point Numa Moon because
he's, I got a, I don't want him shit.
I never even trained it. Like come
on pussy, you're scared. Like, no,
I don't want to, I
don't have to. You know,
and that's just cause rumble
was really good at it.
It doesn't mean he has to keep doing it.
Yeah.
Now he's going to go knock
down airplanes out of the sky.
All right, last thing is
a giant. Are you drunk?
What happened to you?
You just fell apart.
You like in the middle of that
referred, you lost faith in it, right?
I can see it in your face.
They're like,
I'm just going to follow
through with this.
I'm just going to leave
this tear down here. Yeah,
I think he's got to do something
with football. Is involved with uh,
the rams or something like that in
the like the business side of it.
That's the rumor I heard. I shouldn't
be spreading rumors, but uh, anyway,
real good dude to rumble.
Johnson always been a super
nice guy like that dude.
And again,
that highlight reel that he has head
kick knock out of Kevin Burns mean he's,
that's crazy. Knockouts
man. The duty knocked out.
The one from the ultimate fighter.
Jesus Louisa's remember that? Oh,
he's a beast.
Every time he hits somebody
square their knees buckle. Yeah,
he hits them and their needs. It's like
electric heats the body in the shit.
It's like the whole body tenses up.
It's really interesting
because he obviously has a
very good technique and the
throws his body into everything very well.
And you know,
like he's obviously a really strong guy,
but the strength that he has,
the power that he has in his striking
is almost like you're born with that.
Like he has all the elements
to accentuate that power.
Like he has all the technique and he
has, his movement is excellent. He's,
he's quick.
So like as he's delivering these shots,
it's really well timed but it's,
there's more than that. There's,
there's a component that is like a natural
gift that he asked for hitting really
hard.
And then it's what separates him.
It's like you have all these
people that are like really,
really dangerous and then you have rumble.
It's like he's in this total different
dimension of his own where you just can't
get hit if you get hit,
you're fucked.
And the only guy has been able to
absorb it somehow is Cormier. Yeah.
Yeah. And he barely was. That's
why like, I mean that's why I love,
I mean for me it's really growing
on me so much lately is like,
cause he did absorb that you have a crowd,
like not give him credit for
being an outstanding wrestler.
And barely avoiding,
you know,
I mean he did got his head got hit by
rumble in that first bite especially and
like it all started coming down,
but he was avoided it and bought a battle.
It's a battle and like getting hit and
recuperating is a huge part of it and not
getting stuck in a choke hold by a
wrestlers. Another part of it. Yeah.
And you know,
[inaudible] survived his
spark and it surprises me
that the crowd is against him.
I think that fight against Silva sort
of heard him with a crowd because of
course, yes, he's going to
wrestle the shit out of Salva.
What are you going to do?
I don't think that was it.
I think it was all the John Jones stuff
is the fact that he got the title sort
of in what many people consider
an illegitimate manner.
Meaning are they strip Jon Jones,
which makes sense that they stripped him,
you know,
he violated the code of the organization
and he personally and mentally fucked
up,
made giant mistakes.
But everybody knew that John was the
baddest motherfucker on the planet when it
came to 205 pounds.
There was one dude that dude was Jon
Jones and the only thing that was beaten,
John Jones is it.
John Jones wasn't training and Jon Jones
did this press conference the other day
with Daniel two and 10 was talking about
kinds of ship. John went deep. He goes,
I beat you after a weekend of cocaine.
Do you know? And to Michael Johnson
was cry and laugh and he was like,
Oh shit. Oh Shit. That's the most
cold blooded stuff in the world.
I mean the Diaz brothers,
you know,
blatantly smoking pot and beating
up their opponents is one thing.
It's a brag about doing an entire
weekend of cocaine to Jon Jones.
A bad motherfucker. Cause they mean
nobody just does cocaine. Right.
That means you've been drinking
probably hooking up or whatever.
I mean that seems to be helped.
Most people do cocaine. I
don't know how it works,
but it doesn't seem like that
thing. You just, you by yourself.
You know what Jon Jones
can be the best of all time. Really
could still, it's only 30 years old.
You've got to realize one way for us to
know Daniel for me has to do cocaine for
a week to ag. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I cut you off.
I think.
I think Daniel in that fight was
hampered by emotion and I think that John
Really got under his skin and really
taunted him and got him fired up to the
point where it was detrimental to them.
He got overcome with emotion. John,
it's good shit talker man.
We did an interview,
whereas I sat in the middle
and Daniel sat to my right.
Charles had to my lab and dude,
John's ruthless.
He's so ruthless. It's a whole another
part of the game. Rack it up there with,
you know,
with boxing and Jujitsu,
but you didn't even get to see it and
they didn't even put part of it online.
The best of the best shit. But I'm
just saying about shit talking overall,
but I'm saying Jon Jones is shit
talking to Daniel called me.
The best part did he would get online.
The best part he was calling
them is pussy. He's like,
he goes, you're my pussy.
He goes, you're always going to be
my person. He does. I'll fuck you up.
Every time we fight, it's
just like, he's like,
it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter
what, what happens? He goes, you know,
every time we fight out,
fuck you up. He goes,
you're supposed to be a big time
wrestler. He goes, I took you down man,
because you're an Olympic wrestler.
I took you down. He's like,
I beat your ass and you could,
Daniel was very mad. I mean,
the two of them were, it was very intense.
I was that face to face interview. Yeah.
It was intense in the middle
and like a director's chair. No,
that's how Max Kellerman
does it. Uh, you know. Yeah.
I wasn't a director share
Max Kellerman does it,
I think better honestly because like Max
Kellerman does is he sort of faces the
screen and the fighters face each other
beside him to his right into his left.
We had it almost like a sort of a
semi circle. And so, uh, the fighters,
it would have been better if we did
it at a table the way HBO did it,
but it was the only time we ever did
it and it was very, very intense.
It was very intense. John John
says he's a bad motherfucker dude.
And like DC had this whole crew
with them and John Jones was like,
I'll fuck all you up. I'll fuck you
up. He goes, don't look at me big boy.
I'll fuck you up like I do.
I do.
To scare him with the dudes and stare at
them and try to give him some attitude.
John's just straight up looks at
it was like, I'll fuck you up.
I'm looking at me like that. You think is
going to make it to this fight? Oh yeah,
for sure. Yeah, for sure. He's not
going to fuck this up. And it's,
what's fascinating to me is
when you watch these guys,
John had each other when no one can see.
That's when you know there's no press.
There's me and a couple of the people
that are around for the UFC employees. Me,
this is real.
Like this is,
this is two guys trying to get under each
other's skin and John was very good at
it. So this was after the first fight
when they were supposed to fight for the
second time and then it got canceled and
John got stripped and the whole deal.
So now,
now they're finally going to go after it.
But John's only been back in the octagon
once since then against [inaudible] St
Crute.
Yeah.
Yeah. I remember that. We were at the bar,
so all this shit's been going down and
the only time John's been in the cage
since all this shit went down
because the open st pursuit of,
they were originally going to rematch.
He fought over in Saint Peru.
He beat him,
but he felt like he was off.
It seemed like it was good. Big. I
think overtake proves real good. Yeah.
And I also think he wasn't
planning for open st pro.
They have the WHO's planning
for someone else, you know,
that was when Daniel got injured,
wasn't it? No, the day and get injured.
I don't even remember. I'm not even going
to look it up. How about that folks?
The point being that's
an interesting fight man,
because they're going to go at it again
in July and now Cormier has got all this
momentum on his side.
Core me a beat rumble.
He defended against Gustafson or
did he beat Gustovsen to win it?
Uh, cause it was, it was rumble
core may be rumbled a win it. That's
how he got the title. That's right.
And then he defended against Gustafson
and then he defended against her.
I'm home.
Yeah.
And he just rubbed Silva and a non
title mentioned between, that's right.
That's right. And that was a
weird fight. Yeah, that was,
yeah. Double leg. Take down shoe
low. Call it the room. Yeah, he does.
Was a bigger man. That's a
wrestler. Should, I mean if it,
it's one of those like if it ain't
broke, don't fix it things right. Yeah.
Well Cormier is just such a stud wrestler.
You ever see his fight with Dan Anderson?
It's been awhile.
Dan Henderson, who's a beast, you know,
he's a former Olympic wrestler himself,
but just not really the
same size and call me a,
just threw him around man. I mean
just through him all over the place.
I think he choked him out too.
When you choke them unconscious,
that'd be just manhandled them and you
realize like how strong call me a really
is and how good his wrestling really is.
It's like super,
super high level shit man.
That play last night that's
stole the show was uh,
chase,
Chase Sherman and Rashad cold.
Oh my. Yeah. Good Lord
rock 'em sock. 'Em robots.
Crazy in and off they go.
It was interesting because again,
like,
I don't know what you guys are saying
and commentary or just far enough away
where I can't hear you.
Like I ain't notice that the guy,
not leshawn but his opponent,
Rashad, Rashad leshawn just
giving some random black day.
I'm from an all black neighborhood.
I just call everybody listening. Um,
he was kicking Rashad's leg over
and over again to where we shot,
couldn't use it,
but then he kept going for this knock
out instead of just keeping attacking the
leg.
Like what do you think about that?
Well,
we definitely got a little anxious and
he allowed Russia to get back into it by
walking them with some
haymakers but you know,
it's just part of what's going to come
with experience. He's a young kid.
I'm thinking he's only 24 years old,
24,
25 Sherman and um,
if I remember correctly and he's under
the tutelage of Alan Belcher. And um,
so he's like, I think he's got like real
potential. Matt, you start also done some,
uh, some work in Albuquerque. I think
he was there with a Winkeljohn no,
the um, Jackson people in
Albuquerque, so, so great coaching,
look real good man. Look real
good on his feet and just, just,
it was a slobber knocker man. Crazy
back and forth, heavyweight fine.
But if that kid can get it together,
like he's got real good movement,
real good kicks, just got to make good
choices. Like decide when to go in,
when to charge for, when to put
yourself in danger. He didn't have to,
he could've kept doing what he was doing.
That dude was kind of
incapacitated with those leg kicks.
Yeah. It was a firework show. Yeah.
I'm one of those ones. Where was that?
Is that guy from American top team too?
Who? The shot? No, that his
opponent. Sherman. No, no,
no. He was a, I'm pretty
sure he's with Jackson's.
That American top team had like
so many fighters like oh yeah,
Billy, right. Yeah, it's pretty
crazy. And they all did pretty good.
Yeah. Yeah, they did pretty good.
I mean y'all wanna one obviously
junior got knocked out. Um,
well one was called a job at
the Eddie Alvarez is neat,
but that was,
well Mazda dog who's American top team
lost to Maya and as close to decisions
you're ever going to get.
It was a split decision and then
Daniel was trying to lose, try out.
He was like,
he give the guy more credit for doing
damage for the first half of the round or
do you give the guy more credit for being
able to control the guy and go after
submissions for the second half of
the round and what is worth more?
It's a really good question because the
mosfet all Damien Maia fight like one
round of it particularly like the second
round is a really good like case study
and judging and maybe like
athletic commissions should
review that fight and say,
hey,
this is a,
this fight is a really good example of
a fight where it's really subjective.
Like we, and we have to kind of quantify
what, what is more important. Like if you,
if you got the exact same amount of
time but one thing hurt the guy and one
thing didn't, is that a, uh,
you know, is that uh, uh,
does it go towards,
does it go go towards a kickboxer or did
it go towards to like the one half of
the round where the guy was fighting
off being strangled for every second of
that two and a half minutes?
Where do you think, I don't know.
It's an interesting argument.
Like on one side I feel like Mosbey Dell
did more damage and that that should be
worth something. But in the second part
of it, like he was threatening at Mazda.
Dahl wasn't threatening at
all once my got on his back,
you know, so once my I got on his
back is like, Jesus man, this is a,
this is a constrictor on top
of you. Yeah. And you know,
Mosfet all did defend at one time and
at the end of one of the rounds, uh,
got the first round I believe,
got my office back and landed some good
shots at Maya was trying to take them
down and control them again.
So he did get off some damage.
So arguably he could have got that round
because he did a little damage in the
beginning.
My,
it took him down and defended successfully
and then he did some damage at the
end. But you'd really have to like have
a real conversation about what's most
important.
Is Control most important or is
damaged most important or threat?
Most important because like Mazda Dahl
wasn't close to knocking Maya out.
You didn't have them like
staggering around the cage.
But that could have come at any moment.
Yeah.
So it's like there's threat there and
he's clearly hitting Maya more than my is
hitting him.
So you have to assess like what's more
threatening because when my has got you
down,
it's got your back boy,
there's a really high likelihood
you're getting choked.
But yet Mazda it all figured
out a way to get out of that.
So he should also get a little bit
of credit for his great defense,
but more credit should be tomorrow to
Maya's control and my as attacking in
Maya's owning the position,
like he pretty much controlled
the position for a good
chunk of that fight when
he got the back or when he got
him on the ground. So it's a,
it's a weird conversation.
Judges last night with the Texas State
Athletic Commission, some of them,
did these people like work with, are they
the same people that are in the Vegas?
Sometimes it depends on the
commission. I, that's a good question.
I think I would have to,
I'd have to look it up to be sure.
But I think some commissions will
bring in more experienced guys.
They'll hire people like
especially with the referees,
you see that there's referees.
I curb dean's like super
experienced and you know,
you get like Eve Levine's also
super experienced Dan Burglar Yada,
super experienced and you get these guys,
you'll see them all over the place,
they'll do it.
So you ask her dean after that,
Eddie Alvarez,
I don't know if we heard yeah,
the answer,
well her first of all,
herb is like one of the most reasonable
and logical guys will ever talk to after
a fight like that. He's not,
he's not emotional at all. He's,
and it's one of the reasons why I
think he's like the gold standard.
It's him in big John McCarthy and
my eyes were the best of the best.
And you know, not that there's
anything wrong with the other people.
It's a lot of great referees. I think
Dan Burglar Yada does a great job too.
But uh, herb is so like
calm in there. He's,
he just makes good decisions.
And he is a not a fan at all
of guys playing that game
of touching the hand down
to the ground and avoiding the knee.
He thinks it's bullshit.
Anythings if you get hit when
you're playing that game, he's,
he's going to let it go. He's like
just too, it's too much of a scrap,
like any offers of saying this is a fist
fight and he's just trying to win and
there's, he's pulling triggers and
they're in questionable moments.
The referee's not stopping him. He's not
saying is he's down to fighters down.
Like you can't even see sometimes if
you're holding onto a guy, oh you're in a,
a situation where you're
just a few inches from him.
You're not sure whether or not
his hand is touching the ground.
Fuck you are sure you can
fucking knee him in the head.
A lot of times you're just going
to go for that knee to the head.
You got to take that chance.
And I think that's what Eddie said
and I think Dustin believed him too.
Cause you know Dustin's stood up for
him in the, the post fight interview.
He was like,
don't you do this band?
It's like he's the guy who got hit with
the illegal shot and he was still saying,
don't do this God.
So I asked her after the fight,
I said, what did you think that
go? These are the old rules, right?
So if the, if it's the old
rules and one hands down, uh,
then it's illegal, right?
He goes, yes, he goes,
but I don't feel like it was
bearing weight. He goes, you know,
he's definitely playing the game. And he
definitely was putting his hands down,
but I felt like the first time it wasn't
bearing weight and that's how I define
it. And he's like, and then the second
time, uh, it was a legit mistake.
The second time was,
was definitely illegal,
but I felt like he was in the middle
of throwing it when it all happened.
And I think he's correct in that.
So he's the guy that's closest to the
action and he's got to make like the most
pertinent decision.
I also think it's going to be a weird
issue with referees that do events that
have the new rules.
And then do events that have the old
rules and it's pretty much universally
agreed that the new
rules are the way to go.
So with the touching and
the hands on the mat,
it's going to be interesting to see
if there's like an interpretation that
favors the way the new rules
perceive it versus the old rules.
Cause that's how her kind of referee
that fight. He went with the sort of the,
the feeling of the new rules or like
what people want out of the new rules,
but still within the confines he believes
and he knows it better than me of the
old rules. Why weren't the new
rules adopted for Texas last year?
I don't know.
You know,
I mean I think it's probably
different with each organization.
They have to make decisions
and they decide themselves
whether or not they have,
I mean it might be a budget issue and
maybe they don't have the time to review
it. I don't know. It might be a, they
disagree, you know, I who knows man.
And you know,
these athletic commissions can make their
own decisions when it comes to that.
But as far as like the good of the sport,
it would be nice if we
all agreed and I think,
I don't think the real concern would be
whether or not it's bad for the safety
of the fighter.
I don't think it is because I think
it encourages fighting more than an
encouraged stall techniques.
So if you give someone a stall technique,
the ability to put your hands on the
ground, you won't get kneed in the face,
you're going to take it.
Some guys are,
in some situations it's going to be a
desperado move that if it's there you're
going to reach for it. But if it's
not there, you won't reach for it.
So like it terms of like the actual
effectiveness of overall fighting and like
the realism of real, of of
fighting. It's better to get it out.
We don't want it in there because I don't
think it really does protect people.
I think the people that are going
to get need are going to get need.
I think what it does is it
protects you for that brief moment,
but in the decision that
you make to do that,
like you're making a
purely defensive decision,
you're putting your hands on the mat,
both of them.
So this guy can't need you in
the face. That's, you know,
that's like not a good sign
in a fight. Right. You know,
you're in a bad position and sometimes
you can rebound from a that position,
no doubt about it. But it's, I
don't think we should reward,
I don't think you should have these
escape routes where somebody can touch the
mat and not yet be able to. It's
like I'm on base safe, you know?
So I think her was right ultimately,
but according to the right,
the strict interpretation of the rules,
it was an illegal blow.
So it was interesting that
he made it a no contest.
You can sort of get away with
that Sorta as leeway. Right.
Well, it's, um, you know, it's open to
interpretation. I guarantee you the,
I haven't read anything online, but I
guarantee you it'll be a controversial,
I mean it's just a hot button subjects
to people to be debating it back and
forth and there's going to be people
that agree with her is going to be people
that disagree with them. But um, you know,
ultimately that's the toughest
job next to being a fighter.
It MMA did get be the guy who has to make
those calls and I give them a shit ton
of respect,
man.
I used to be on a baseball umpire,
like for little league and that,
that was hard and like to think
like, man, so much passion. Yeah.
It's like a tie in. If I go safe that
this side goes crazy, but if I go out,
that's side goes crazy and it's so close.
And to think that those guys have to
make those decisions we do to health and
lies that those are fathers and children
and brothers and sisters and everything
and like that's crazy gig.
Yeah.
Knowing how many punches and whether
the person's just sort of seems like
they're out of it or if there's still
defending themselves and their whole
livelihood. Yeah. Crazy job.
Yeah, it is a crazy job, Ben. It's, um,
and you have to know a lot about MMA
and you have to really understand when a
guy's actually in trouble, when
you need to step in, you know,
you have to have seen a
bunch of guys get hit.
You got to know when a guy has done
and it's subjective and you know,
you can make bad calls and
sometimes you make bad calls.
There's nothing you can do about it. I
mean, the early days, big John McCarthy,
uh,
was refereeing a fight between Matt
Lindland and Barolo Bustamante and Marilla
booster Montay taps Matt Lindland. And
then Lynn Lynn said that you didn't tap.
So they restarted the fight and they
went back at it again and then Bustamonte
tapped them again at later round.
So he tapped him twice in the same fight
when it happened. And when you were
commentating? I believe so. And like,
did you see him tap on the video?
Do you remember?
Trying to remember if I was commentating.
It's hard to remember.
It's like they all get blurry after a
while. I'm pretty sure I was, but man,
I might not have been. Now that I think
about it, I'll have to go back and listen.
But I remember the fight clearly cause
I remember I remember going, oh no,
it's stood him up and now they're going
to make them fight again. I'm like,
that's crazy. You already
won though. He Won.
Like all you got to do is look at the
replay and you get see Lindland Tab.
And he said, look, he's, if they
give him another chance to fight,
he's going to take another
chance to fight. If he can.
Con is way back in the fight and
he's going to do it. So he, he said,
I didn't tell him because have to go back
in there again. That's a ball or move.
It's a jump ball or move.
I didn't have,
I was just moving my hand bag.
Well more ball or move his Bustamonte
tapping them again is there go really.
And then he caught him with
the GFC and the second time,
but that's happened before.
That's happened in fights before we'd
guys said they didn't tap when they did.
And so because of that people have been
forced to like hold submissions and you
know, and wait till the referee
like literally separates them.
But that's also what got people like
people are super sensitive about that with
knee bars. Like what? Chokes
doesn't seem to bother be bliss.
Much like people don't get mad
if somebody holds onto it. Shows
speaking nice.
Another thing I thought was really cool,
the last thing with the other female fight
and the lady's kicks from her back.
Oh yeah.
Unbelievably effective. Cortney
Casey. Yeah, right on the kneecap.
Trying to hyper extend those legs.
And even from our angle it looked
like it was really working.
You could see her leg bending back
and she didn't want to fuck with that.
After awhile.
No.
In the beginning crowd was going crazy
cause the bigger girl dragged her to the
middle of the ring by your foot. You know
what I mean? It got the crowd into it.
But as the fight went on,
she was beating the shit out of her from
her back with feed. It was very, very,
very awesome.
Again,
like I wish I knew what you guys were
talking about over there because over
there I'm like, it's interesting because
you're sort of watching fight in arena.
You're sorta like on an island
by yourself when you're not,
we need under the headset on
and you can't hear you guys. But
watching it right in front of you too,
you're not really seeing it on
the monitor is very much. Right,
exactly.
So it's all very like,
we're just trying to make sure
that what you're seeing is real.
It's weird not hearing you guys.
I hear you guys everywhere else at
home on the Internet, on the phone,
but you're that close to the action.
Yeah, it's habit. It's bizarre. Yeah.
So what were you guys,
what was that like where you going?
Well I was impressed.
Well saying that like what she's doing
is like kind of next level up kicking
like are up kicks were so good and
that was making a mistake. I mean,
right in front of her. It was Daniel's
point and then Aguilar's Niesr are jacked.
She kept getting hyper
extended and Daniel's saying
all the different things she
could do to avoid that,
but I was just so impressed with
Courtney Casey's up kegs. I was like,
she's taken up, kicks to the next
level and I'm thinking like, man,
I bet up kicks here. Just one of those
things that if you just practice it,
you get really good at it.
I bet we haven't really seen
the full potential of appkit's.
I bet somebody would just be so deadly
that you wouldn't even want to get close
to them when they're on their,
yeah,
bad. Right. Imagine that opponent, the
one that just lays down as soon as the,
just pretend to fall down and
fuck you up off their back.
Hey,
I still feel like Nate Diaz was setting
a trap for Conor in that second fight.
Those two times
that could have very well big,
right.
Totally see him move. Trying to make it
look like that was one of their plans.
Make it look like Conor
got me on the chin.
Like Connor overreact and then
did he say that? Did he say that?
I never officially heard it.
He may have said it in like a post
press conference or something,
but it felt like a mousetrap
to me and I don't even know.
I don't even know if he would admit
that if, if it, even if he would,
because I don't think he'd
want to give away strategies.
Right, right. Well I think, look,
he's got such a giant
advantage on the ground.
Imagine if Nate Diaz became like a
killer wrestler. Like Nate Diaz is like,
you know Kevin Randleman
back in the day like, shoot,
these power doubles and Kevin
dudes on the ground like Nate Diaz,
his ground game is very high level man.
He's super nasty and mixing up
strikes with his submissions too.
Like what's set up? That's a mission.
First of all is the strikes on the feet.
He popped Connor and the jaw had them
rocks and they got him on the ground.
It was busting them up on the ground and
then Conner gave up his back trying to
escape the mount and he chokes up mean
beat him standing up. Yup. That's
shot. Connor took was absolute garbage.
Oh, he was just, it was really hurt.
Yeah. Yeah. He was just trying to hang on.
It was just trying to hang on.
It's Harvard. Was that right
last week? Said that too.
Tarver yeah. The guy who was the
Alexa. Yeah. He's, you know, he's the,
I'm new striking coach for American
top team. Oh really? Oh Wow.
I did not know that. Or the
black zillions. I'm sorry.
The black zillions. Sorry.
Yeah, he's, the new striking
coach was backstage. Man,
that's such an offensive
thing that I just said.
You don't even know blacks don't answer
the American top team of a giant, uh,
they have a giant rivalry with each other.
So that's the point where they had
an ultimate fighter where they,
the two teams faced off against
each other for a whole season.
So my apologies to American top
team. Black zillions go. Either way.
Tarver is a bad motherfucker. Remember
when he knocked out Roy Jones. Yeah.
Amazing Dude.
Anyway,
he said that it should be Nate Diaz
going up against Floyd Mayweather because
Niki as be Conor McGregor and I'm
totally on that same wavelength.
Reds like, yeah, what are
we talking about here?
Like I just want to see more of
the Diaz brothers overall anything.
I guess that's my thing is that,
well, I agree that it definitely
was still sell a shit ton of money.
That's a shit ton of paper views.
Rather make a shit ton of money. I mean,
I just don't think that Nate Diaz has
the international appeal to Connor has,
right?
Nate Diaz should,
Nate Diaz and America as a Goddamn hero
and I don't think the UFC is totally
aware of what a big star he is.
I think so either. I think, I think
he's, he could be just three, four,
five fights away from me. My Gregory
is to Ireland. Yeah, from Mexico.
He's American, Bro. I know.
Trust me, we're all American,
but my point is like,
you know, they need that.
I think. I think UFC really still
needs huge Mexican superstar.
I think that they've had them, and
I don't mean from Mexico, Mexico,
I mean like just Mexico.
Does that help people get into it
and it's a big part of it? Well,
that's one of the champions.
One of the things that people are
excited about what the IEA Rodriguez, uh,
but it just bit off way more than he could
chew last night against Frankie Edgar.
Frankie just mauled him.
Yeah. Like literally Malden.
The best defense is a good offense
and he just kept going at it. Well,
yeah, as a person who's a kicker,
like you, you realize when you're,
you're kicking and you're standing on
one leg, I mean, you're vulnerable.
You're just more vulnerable to being
taken down by a guy who's an elite MMA
wrestler. And when I say MMA wrestler, I
mean the guy was used to catching kicks,
understands where the kicks are coming,
where they're coming from,
knows when it's happening.
There's no hesitation. Dives
on it and takes you down.
No, thank you. No, no, thank you. I know
I'm good at, I'm good at everything. Okay.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Feel like I've been watching Frankie
Edgar forever. You have been,
I mean he beat Bj Penn for the title Shit.
I don't know when it was,
but I want to say it was
like 2008 or nine maybe.
That was a long time ago.
Man,
he's still in the heat at one 45 I mean
he proved with that fight that he is in
the heat.
He looks great.
Afterwards he walked out near us and
like it's like didn't even look like he
fought that day.
Very amazing.
Yeah. It just goes to show you how
good although really is, you know,
cause all of those already beaten
them twice. Yeah. The thing is, man,
I want to see all doe vs Mcgregor,
but it's a hard sell.
When someone knocks you out in 13 seconds,
it's super hard to say. I got an and
you've got to get a second shot at him.
I think it goes both ways.
I think it makes it hard to get another
shot at him and I think it makes it easy
to get another shot at them because we
know that's like God damn nominally.
I know we would all feel silly if,
say they did it again and he knocked
him out in eight seconds and we're like,
are you
good? Let me tell you something.
He could. Connor could
if does that,
that we melt down that belt.
We melt down the gold into a crown and
you cut it on Connor's head and you say
you're done. Go enjoy your
crown. Done. You're on your,
you're now on game of Thrones.
You're no longer a fighter.
Isn't that an amazing as the
land he requested a crown. Yeah.
I don't fight for belts anymore.
I fight for crowns.
I melted my belt into the crown.
That's a terrible accident. That's a,
I don't do that.
That's what the undertaker once did.
Even ones melted down
the WWF belt into like a,
a championship, like a necklace.
Didn't really, no, it wasn't
actually, I wasn't him.
That was like a, the Godfather.
That was like a pimp. He was like,
he won the ww belt and the had the gold
melted down into like a pimps left.
Oh my God. Basically fuck
yo belt. That's hilarious.
My necklace now. I love the
storylines like that. Oh yeah.
It's wrestling is so campy.
It's so silly as my,
the thing about wrestling as though,
man, when you joke around about it,
people get super upset who they supported.
Oh,
they get upset.
They get sort of very happy to.
I think it goes both ways.
It takes those real more
on Nigga upset about it.
There's a lot of real morons out
there though. Hey, you had me up,
said that one time saying that it was
not real and we know it's not real.
Like that part's not surprising.
But you kept saying that like
game of Thrones was a real,
you're watching a play. You go to see
musicals. It might as well be singing.
Sometimes they sing on wrestling too.
You know Daniel Cormier is a big
wrestling fan. Oh yeah. I'm sure he is.
He's a silly fellow.
Yeah,
but there's definitely a lot of that.
I mean we talked about this years ago
on a podcast where I said, you know,
I think more elements of pro wrestling
in the UFC would do him justice because
it's just makes for entertainment.
And since then this, you know,
this Irishman has become a big deal,
the Diaz brothers and
these tough characters.
We're starting to just find out more
about the characters and that's sort of
what I meant.
Nothing fake or anything,
but just the entertainment part is a big
side of the UFC and it's a big side of
boxing and it's a big side of
the wall of sports. And uh,
I think the UFC is like really embracing
that and also having a little bit of
trouble embracing it,
but also embrace it.
Well,
I think they definitely embrace it,
but you also have to respect the
hierarchy of championship. Like when the,
like the Amanda Nunez Ronda Rousey thing,
when they were doing that big promo and
they were only featuring Ronda Rousey,
I don't know whose decision that was.
I'm not going to criticize them.
They did their best.
They created a very interesting,
compelling little peeps that
got me fired up about the fight.
I fired up about the fight when I saw
that. So they did a good job on it,
but I don't think they paid nearly enough
attention to the danger that is Amanda
Nunez.
And I think that if they showed that,
it would have made it even more
compelling as Amanda's a fucking monster.
That chick hits hard,
she's ferocious,
she's nasty on the ground and she
knows how to win and she's an attacker.
And if they just showed the highlights,
man just showed her, beaten up,
Misha Tate strangling her. They
showed her putting it to people, man,
the way she did the Sarah Coffin
or not Sarah Copy Sam Mcmahon did.
She's a beast.
And so they didn't even really concentrate
on it and she was the champion.
And I was like, well that's silly.
I got them all for the showbiz part.
But you're missing out on one star here.
You're focusing on one on your current
star and missing out on an opportunity to
highlight a new star,
by the way.
And that's not even,
that's what I'm saying is that that
isn't the show. Best Way to do it.
The show Biz way to do it
is to pump up nooner. Yes.
And to show that when like if
Vince Mcmahon was running it.
I know that sounds crazy,
but that's what he would do is since
he doesn't know who's going to win,
he would pump up Nunez instead of Rhonda.
We already know Rhonda.
So when Rhonda Beats Nunez,
it's like Ron does bad.
You didn't know,
I had heard that Vince Mcmahon
was thinking about buying
the UFC when it was for
sale. Crazy. That would
have been if he took over.
He's bought all of his other competition
except for boxing throughout history.
And I think the UFC is obviously not
competition, but I think that uh,
I think it would have been interesting
to see what he would've done.
It would've been interesting to see if
he would have let it keep building or if
he would've just cut it out
and disintegration. Yeah.
Well it's also interesting,
we'll just see whether or
not it's problematic to
have a guy from the show Biz
side of athletics,
which there's no doubt about it.
Those pro wrestlers are fucking athletes.
Yeah.
You can't look at Brock Lesnar
and tell him he's not an athlete.
You can't look at John Cena. Tell me he's
not an athlete. The Rock, all those guys,
they're fucking stud athletes.
No doubt about it. Yeah.
I don't know another gay guy.
Yeah, that's mark was the guy that, yeah,
like when Bronc Lester did that three
60 flip in the air and landed on his
fucking head and still finish the match,
like okay,
that's if you like Cirque de Solei.
Do you think those people are athletes?
For sure. This guy, this
is a serious athlete. Yeah.
But there's also the fact
that it's entertainment.
So if a guy goes from that side of
the business and then it goes to the,
the side of the business where
it's supposed to be pure sport,
which is the pure sport MMA,
right.
And a sport that has
always had a reputation,
or at least the whispers of being fixed.
You're always hearing about a fixed fight.
Like in Japan in particular,
you heard about a bunch of fixed fights
and there was a recent case where
someone in the UFC had an offer to fix
a fight but didn't go through with it.
But there was evidence,
apparently there's a big story about
couple of couple weeks ago about the first
evidence that someone was
attempting to fix a fight.
So even though it didn't get fixed,
someone had tried to put influence
on someone to fix a fight, allegedly.
But in pride,
we know for a fact it happened.
I know that I know firsthand from
people that were in fixed fights.
I know from people that were told that
a fight was going to be fixed for them.
So it's,
it's not,
it's not speculation whether or not there
was fights that had been fixed in the
past. So to have a guy like Vince
McMahon come over and run things,
they would have to be a
very clear delineation.
I think he'd have at least really good
ideas. Oh really? No doubt about it.
But I know this, the Diaz brothers would
be fighting and it would be crazy shit.
It'd be Connor versus nick after
the neat thing, and it would be,
I think you're right. And things like
that because it's, he knows that pop,
you know what they do is they
just listened to the crowd.
That's how they write it.
It's not like some thing where
he's going to stick to some,
well sometimes he does.
That's why everybody hates that one
guy Roman reigns because he just keeps
letting him win,
which is like for the first time a
storyline that we've never even heard of.
This is the crowd hates this guy,
but they keep letting him win.
So now he gets nothing that heat, nothing
but booze because we were like, fuck,
this guy sucks. Why? We know you're
going to let him win. It makes no sense.
So he's fucking with us really good.
But other than that guy,
other than that exception, he listens
to the crowd and then like you know,
I mean it's just another perfect example.
Looking back with a new nose Rhonda thing.
Looking at that analogy,
he would have focused
on the Diaz brothers.
Any would have focused on Nate waking
up and smoking a joint and going for a
run. Like he would embrace that side
of that storyline because that is the
interesting part. That's what
everybody's saying about, you know, the,
the Jon Jones for me, I think over
the er at that presser is like,
I did cocaine all weekend and beat you
up with the Diaz brothers have been
running triathlons while drinking
tequila and smoking joints.
Like it's nothing like,
they don't even think about that.
It's like how we have a cup
of coffee in the morning.
They literally smoke a joint. I read
an in thing, they smoke a joint,
but for getting up and going on a
10 mile run the fuck outta here.
This guys their hand. I'm also,
and that should be embraced.
That should be talked about.
That should be part of their storyline.
That's what I love about
them is because by the way,
even though I'm not a super athlete,
that's sort of how I live.
I like smoking pot.
I like drinking at night with my friends
and I think I still can get my work
done and do all that and
have fun and be productive.
And that's sort of where I connect
with those guys and why I liked her.
So granted,
I'm a comedian,
it's more fitting for my lifestyle
to be able to smoke pot and drink,
but I think that them being able to do
all that inspirational and goes to show
you that you can have fun and work
hard and work hard and have fun.
Yeah,
they're really unusual too in that most
people associate triathletes and you
know athletes
and we'll likely that you don't think
of them as like thugs, you know?
But you think of Nick Diaz,
you think of it as this bad motherfucker
that also happens to run triathletes.
He's not like some granola crunch and
I can just street dude who knows how to
fight and then at the same time he is
what? I'll have another one. Me Too.
Please. Thank you very much. Thank
you. It's funny because like yeah,
they're there. They go both
ways to where it's like, yeah,
that's a thug street dude.
If you look at his Instagram,
you see him in this like little bicycle
outfits. The guys on bicycles, the way
Nick Diaz wearing a fucking bicycle
helmet get out of here. What?
He has a hilarious story about getting
in a Bra. In one of those things,
people didn't know any better
like something happened.
He was riding a bike and he wound up
getting a fight with this other dude is
riding a bike and a couple of dudes at
the same time. It takes one Duke down,
get some any heel hook fucks his leg up.
Some other dude,
I've got back on his bike control off,
but just they fucked with them.
The of the mayor in a bicycle race
and you're like, you know what?
I'm mad at this guy. I'm going to
start a fight with this guy. Hey Man,
if you'd want to go looking for fights,
you can find them.
Here's a lot of people out there that
are just looking for a fight. I mean,
if I was going to look for a fight,
that's where I would look for a bunch
of people racing bicycles, right?
Boy, did you fuck up and he picked a
fight with Nick Diaz. You're like, wait,
this dude is a little bicycle shorts.
I'm gonna beat his ass.
All of a sudden you're like, why is
my knee sideways rips? What a fucking,
what a crazy move to doing up
street fight. He heal hooks.
You tears your Nia part.
That's what's interesting.
You know, and not only that aspect but
so many more with those guys. It's like,
yeah.
And they also look like street fighters
that are going to punch you in the face,
but they're also great
seeing high level black belt.
You know, Jujitsu super hardest.
Yeah, 100% of the highest degree.
So it's like they just,
because,
and I think that helps and that perception
like psychologically like it's like,
you know,
it makes you think like fuck this con,
but you're realizing that there's
eloquent beauty coming at you in the art.
It's just because they look one way.
It's almost a distraction of like,
it's almost like a Venus fly trap.
How it's like all pretty and it's like,
you know, the opposite,
but it's like made to,
made to bring you in and then it just
snaps by using its natural element where I
think it's sorta reverse where they
sort of make you think they're punks.
But they're not. They're smart as
fuck and there it's a trap. Yeah.
Yeah. It's good point, man. It's like a,
you would think that dude's
doesn't have that kind of shit.
Talking attitude couldn't really fight,
but they fight real good and they're
real technical and they have crazy
endurance and discipline,
which is what's really weird about it is
how much discipline may have, you know,
you would think a guy,
when a guy would talk a lot of shared
like with something mother fucker stocked
and Motherfucker,
that's not going to be a guy who run
marathons and swim back and forth from
Alcatraz, but it is. That's what's
crazy about. Thank you so much.
Is it okay if your voice is used
in the background of a podcast?
Is it okay if your voice is in
the background of a podcast?
We're recording something. Many people are
going to us. Is that okay? That's fine.
That's okay. Do you have a
beautiful accident? It's great.
It's very pretty.
It's just a comedy podcast and we do,
sometimes we do one on a
plane on occasion. Yeah. Okay,
good. All right, thank you. What's
your name again? Yup, Sylvie.
So thank you. Silvie listening.
Sylvie's our guest for this evening,
Ladies and gentlemen.
You heard it, Sylvie?
A lovely lady with a beautiful accent.
They treat you nice up here and first
class. Yeah, it's fun. Super Nice.
A lot better than being the peasants.
Dude,
I'm going to take your spoon in your
mouth and I'm putting in my coffee.
I don't give a fuck.
How about that dude?
I'm not scared of Shit even
embedded in my mouth. But like uh,
people will share joints that you won't
share a spoon or do you think you're
doing bitch,
don't be scared
with those guys is really wacky and
it's big part of their success, man.
And another crazy thing is that is how
psychologically damming the flatbeds.
Oh, yet the way that guy beat you
have about it is fucking hilarious.
And it's so true.
And because of the bed,
I'd gotten to think about it a lot more
in sort of analyze it a lot more in from
different angles than just as
I was as an MMA fan before.
And really figure out what it
is sort of behind it. I mean,
not that I know more than anybody,
but it's sorta like the guys,
if it makes you overcharge,
all of a sudden they become a matador
and you're the bowl by poking you like
that because if you punch another
guy in the face that's expected,
any of you kick your opponent
in the head that's expected,
but open hand slapping your opponent like
makes people laugh at you and you can
hear like laughter in the crowd.
It's a different type of roar. Right?
Or like that ric flair woo
that you hear a lot lately.
Like ooh that those types of pop's.
I feel like even though you know a lot
of those guys talk about tunnel vision
and this and that,
they can still hear that crowd.
They feed off of that energy
just like anybody does it alive.
Anything and you don't want
to get slapped no matter what.
You just don't.
Randy couture fought
two door Tz spanked him,
got on top of when we stack them
and then we had them stacked.
He was spanking him and
the crowd was going crazy.
Spanked his butt.
Oh Man.
It's ridiculous.
Some ridiculous shit happens in fights.
The first time Nick Diaz
fought Robbie Lawler,
I'll never forget it
because I knew about nick,
I knew about his fights
with Jeremy Jackson,
who is this a really talented striker
that was on the ultimate fighter,
but one of getting in trouble, he was in
jail for something. I forget what it is.
Uh, it might some bad, like you
said, jail for a long time. Um,
but anyway, uh, when I first
saw nick fight Robbie Lawler,
he got into the cage and Robbie Lawler
was a phenom back then. You know,
it was probably like, he's probably
like 20 years old, 21 years old.
And Nick just starts going stucked
in motherfucker. And Robbie's like,
what is this dude said? He said,
come on bitch, come on bitch.
Come on bitch. And while he's calling a
bitch, you could see Robbie Lawler's head.
Like, I can't believe this
dude is calling me bitch. Like,
I can't believe he's telling me a bitch.
He's like trying to get you emotional.
And he got inside Robbie's
head a little bit.
Yeah. Oh, he got in a
fight. Conor said too,
they don't want to show you those
clips, nick. Never Fuck Conor.
Nick did fight. Conor kind being a lot
of trouble next. A different animal.
That would be,
I was saying that would be a really
interesting fight and everybody's like,
Nick Diaz is so much bigger. I'm like,
look, Nick Diaz fight 155 pounds.
Nick Diaz can get to one 70 no problem.
Connor fights at one 70
yeah. That is the fight. Yeah. Or
Nay or Nate. That is the fight. Yeah,
the shamrock versus the pop leaf. Yeah.
Look, I liked the idea of them coming.
That's a good, I liked that
dude. I like that marketing.
They do look Kimmy knuckles on
that shamrock and the pot leaf.
That's strong on Dana White.
Yeah.
They need to hire you and
have some great ideas.
Would you be interested in
trying to turn this ship around?
As for loose battleship has taken on
some damage. I'd be so little with us.
Rhonda gets some water damage. I really,
I'm not even kidding. And I, Hey,
I would love that. And B, I
would actually enjoy it. Like,
I mean like we should have a it out
at it. We should have a meeting. It's,
it was such a fan of both
UFC and entertainment,
but my brain naturally, yeah, you
got to do another fight companion.
Yeah. Those are so much
fun. I missed those.
We haven't had a chance to do one of
those and so long for it. It'll be like,
I think a lot of guys back when,
back in the day when it was just the TV
used to want to be on like the late show
with David Letterman and stuff tonight.
So literally my goal is
to do more FYC companions.
That's so fun. It's like the coolest
thing. Yeah. They're so fun, man.
They're the most fun learning some
of that flat earth. She Jitsu,
they do go off the rails
and the booze gets flowing.
There's just no doubt about it. I'm
both sides. Everybody's side. It's just,
people get so crazy when the boos starts,
but it's,
it's the best way to watch fights
cause you're not interrupting anybody.
It's not like you're like talking to a
lot of shit while you're in the arena and
the other people try to enjoy the fight.
You're just the comfort of
your own little studio there.
You're talking shit with your
friends and people don't have,
like if I did that during commentary,
it would be incredibly disrespectful.
Like if I wasn't watching the fights
when we were talking about Ufo shows or
pussy or feet,
like a big flood or whatever
the fuck we're talking about.
Yeah. You keep it on the fights.
Even yesterday jre and you're like,
let's talk about the fight.
That was a crazy moment.
Oh, it was nice if you wanted to.
Yeah. Jason Knight, crazy motherfucker.
You slip a joke. How can I even
been on the Joe Rogan experience?
Uh, onions have fun. We just did
a companion with wrestlemania.
Me and my pro wrestling friends. We
do a pro wrestling podcasts now. Yeah,
we did a companion to
Wrestlemania five minutes.
We got to do that.
You and I have to do one of those.
It's going to let me know when there's
another big wrestling thing and you and I
will do a wrestling companion.
Yeah.
I'm supposed to do a soccer
companion with Ian too.
Oh Jesus. Why don't you just
do a sleeping companion?
No, no, no. We're going
to get high as fuck.
Then we're going to talk some shit about
soccer and you're going with me to see
Ian knows all lot about soccer. Oh
yeah. Ian Edwards is a real soccer fan.
He does a soccer podcast with some
other dude. I forget who it is.
See, I think soccer's speak. Some
people think wrestling snake.
Uh, uh, I'm here to tell
ya it's real as fuck.
They definitely have some fake
moments in soccer. I'll tell you that.
Like when guys accidentally barely get
touched in the face and they fall down
like they got shot, there's a lot of
bitch shit that goes on in soccer games.
I mean when I say bitch shit with all
disrespect to the bitches out there,
I'll disrespect or respect rather whatever
team that got like possessed by demons.
That's my team bro.
Yeah.
I gave them the Santa Maria before I
told them we're going to win this shit at
all costs.
Some scary shit.
No,
that's when you know someone's retarded.
When they believe in demons. Like it's,
it's a funny thing. I used to have a
bit about this, I need to bring it back.
But the bit was that like you could talk
about God you want and all you want and
nobody freaks out. But if you started
talking about the devil, people go what?
And the bill was at like,
George Bush can go, uh,
make God bless our troops in
Afghanistan and everybody goes,
that's a beautiful sentiment.
But if he says we've located the devil,
he's in Pakistan,
he's in the mountains and we are going
to knock him out of existence and evil
will end on earth. You'd be like,
what? Hold on. Wait a minute. Hold on.
The actual devil. Like you found the
devil and you're going to go shoot him.
Is that what you just said?
What the fuck are you talking about?
You think there's a
real devil? Like if, if,
if someone was on TV and they started
talking about the will of God,
we wouldn't have a problem with it.
But if they started talking about the
devil having influence on all the events
of the world and that we have to repent
and we have to realize the Christian way
is the only path to see like Whoa,
people would go with the fuck
are you talking about the devil?
Like that's the one aspect of Christianity
than in 2017 is super touch and go
with the populace.
Like that's real fringe stuff.
So which shows you like how the religion
is sort of evolving in a weird way.
It's moving away from the most
ridiculous thing to the lease rate.
Like the least ridiculous thing
is like this university is so big,
it's so infinite.
What are the likelihood that something
is far more powerful than US created it?
Probably man,
who knows make sense and what if God is
love and the love that binds us together
and creates everything that is life and
other building blocks of life and it's
all, it's one infinite plan that's
too complex for us to understand.
We can call it God. Okay, I'll
buy that. I'm a smart guy.
I'll buy him a nonsecular
or a secular God,
but when you start talking about
the devil like it actual devil,
like an actual demon that is tempting
you into doing bad things like,
come on bitch,
I can't do this with you.
Like that's too ridiculous
for people today.
Totally.
It's crazy.
That video that you tweeted out a couple
of days ago that had the entire history
of the universe and 10 minutes
isn't that amazing?
So amazing.
And it just goes to show you how silly
religion is because it's like three
minutes into the video for
10 seconds. It's just like
Jesus is born, he's existed.
You worship Jesus. Jesus died and
all the other religions too. Yeah,
but it was just one small part of such
a huge millions of years and hundreds of
thousands of gaps of space in between.
You know what?
I was horrified by in that
video how little I knew,
but what he was talking about,
the empires and the Hawaiian God who,
how many you know happened?
Wow, okay. That's what happened.
Like I really need to like
get a comprehensive,
some sort of a book that will give
me like a great world history.
That's something that's easy to follow
or you know what I need to do, man,
I need to listen to Dan Carlin more
listen to hardcore history. Yeah, but see,
there's just some,
there's so much history.
I mean if you go back thousands of
years like Mesopotamia to today,
how many different things you have to
be aware of how many different events
and thinking about this stuff when I'm
out there in Joshua tree in the middle,
that doesn't it.
I just took one of those trips a few
weeks ago and I'm looking around at these
rocks.
I'm like sort of by myself,
these crazy beautiful mountain ranges
that don't even look real and I'm thinking
like, Oh fuck, have you been doing all
this time? Like yeah, I'm like taught,
you know, not talking to
them but literally like
wondering like, so they just,
it's like
everything's always changing.
It is just as like I see new and
temporary to those mountains.
Like you watched that video of the history
of the world and all of a sudden you
realize those mountains are just
as temporary as a blurb of lava,
but it just doesn't seem temporary to
us because our timeframe is messed up.
But that all that shit used
to be underground like that
Salsa will stall molten
rock from before and it's amazing.
Like the perspective switch on everything,
everything is something else entirely.
That shit was all under water
and it was all in the Mantel.
It was on the center of the earth.
Now it's high up above.
It's all fucking like the crazy,
I mean obviously I was deep on mushrooms
as well, having these thoughts,
but like that's what
it took to get it out.
Yeah, it sometimes takes them like that.
Just to give you a new perspective on it.
You, have you ever been Hawaii?
Not yet. Oh, you gotta go
on the planning on it.
Castillo just went super jealous.
He took his gross battle winnings and
took this girl to Hawaii and the pictures
just send me that looks so fun,
Dude. It's amazing there. It's amazing.
It's a volcano. It's a series of
volcanoes in the middle of the ocean.
They're popping up and there's more of
them that are building up around it.
It's like a a museum that you can go
to his show you the history of Hawaii,
how it was created, and then they also
show you the surrounding islands and, Gee,
I guess it would be like a laba.
Vents are lava,
like volcanoes that are
underwater right now.
They're building up and eventually
break the surface of the water,
but they've actually spot and I think,
I can't remember what part,
I think it was in the South Pacific where
they actually watched islands get born.
They saw volcanic activity and
we're there while islands will,
we're breaking the surface of the water.
Like you can actually see it in some
places and I'm pretty sure they have video
of it. You know, it's basically just
breaching the surface of the water.
But that's how an island is
born and that's what Hawaii is.
Yeah. And then like once
you go above that water,
you're probably never going
back. No, I don't. I don't
think so.
I mean who knows?
I mean maybe millions of years later it
flattens out again or it becomes like
yellow stone and it blows up and
the whole top pops off of it.
That's the nuttiest shit dude.
Super Volcanoes.
Do they think that a super volcano,
I'm want to say,
I'm trying to think of how
many thousands of years ago,
I forget how many thousands of years ago,
it might've been like 60,000 years ago.
It think that the human race might have
gotten down to as few as a few thousand
people. Yeah. That these super volcanoes,
when they below,
they kill enormous amounts of things.
People, animals. But we're so weak, bro.
When we have to live in the natural world,
we have to try to put it out there
with the bears and the Moose and shit.
We don't make it now.
We're only doing like we have been living
with clothes on and with fire for so
long we're such bitches.
Cause even cave people were
bitches compared to animals.
You know you still need a cave by figuring
out caves and by figuring out fire
and how to stay warm, we fucked ourselves.
It's probably what made us smarter.
Yeah. But we, when we first
manipulated our environment,
we first figured out how to
manipulate our environment.
This has been like a bunch of
desserts day, different stages of it,
but one different states. If it was
shelter so you could be safe. So the,
the animals weren't
picking off the soft ones.
So people didn't get as hard as
they were before they had shelter.
If they had some people that survived
that maybe wouldn't have survived a few
decades ago or a few generations ago
or before they figured out caves.
So those people get to fuck and those
soft bitches make more soft pitches.
And then they figured out weapons and
then people survive even further and they,
you know, and like they don't
ever get a chance to beat.
Like if imagine if people would be
people with the brains of people with the
bodies of gorillas,
we'd probably be covered
in hair and arguing. Yeah.
Well it's a compromise because in becoming
softer and softer will become smarter
and smarter.
Right?
Like you don't associate Elan Musk with
being the most shredded barbarian on
earth. Right? No. You associated with a
been a gentleman in a nice suit and a tie.
It was a reasonable human body.
Right.
But when you think about someone who's
like just a super conquer like some Brock
Lesnar type dude,
you don't think of Brock Lesnar inventing
some new way to manipulate traffic in
Los Angeles to cut down commute time from
Santa Monica to lax to three minutes,
go on 130 miles an hour and a fucking
sled underground do this. Right.
I'm not taking Brock
Lesnar's rocket to the moon.
That's a perfect way to describe it
as the perfect way to describe it.
The brocket.
Yeah.
So it's like as as we become
more and more civilized,
we all,
and more and more like innovative,
figuring out new ways
to like stockpile food.
We just get softer and softer and softer.
So when something goes wrong,
like boom, fucking volcano blows up and
you lose everything and it's like it's,
there's no sun anymore.
You can't grow food anymore.
You got to go find things
to eat in the woods.
Everybody dies like
you're almost nobody left.
They got down on a few thousand people
and they say that it happens in North
America every six to 800,000 years.
The Yellowstone just Bolos.
You don't, they didn't even know
about this until satellites,
when they had satellites, when as soon
as they started looking at images,
the Yellowstone region,
they,
there was a theory of if being a Caldera
volcano and then they confirmed it that
the whole yellow stone,
I guess they would call it a base in the
Yellowstone basin is really one giant
crater from a volcano that was so big.
The top blows off and flava shoots like
a mile into the sky or some shit and it
just blocks out everything.
It's like the ultimate super earths zit.
It just, did you ever seen
that website on Instagram?
Instagram page rather Dr Pimple
Popper? Never seen it. It's hilarious.
Is it just this chick is this chick,
she's a doctor but she's a dermatologist
and all she does is like lance assists
in, squeeze them out. You can't look away.
You can't look away.
I know I've watched those
videos but not like that.
I been followed that person yet,
but I bought,
I've gone off on like
youtube tangents of that.
It's just deep Pershing and just
watching it scored out. I'm like,
Hey,
I don't know why I can't stop watching.
But it is interesting like whatever
it goes on deep in our bodies.
It's fucking disgusting.
Well she's amazing at it because she's
a doctor and she has fun with it so it's
hilarious. She has funny captions
that are a little Instagram account.
It's fucking hilarious dude. And
she has exploders. She's, she's,
she's cutting the holes on people's heads
and squeeze out like a banana of pus
and I'm not even exaggerating,
it's just costing.
Some people's bodies are just nasty.
They just have these like
literal softballs on the
side of their face and she
caught someone squeezes out
all this yellow shit and
blackheads the size of your
fist. It's so nasty. I
watch it if you insist
upon it, but the get it,
get it,
get it says
that's like what the super
volcano is in the earth.
It's just like this giant exploding pos
of Laba and it happens all the time,
man. And in terms of like
the, the history of the earth,
it happens every six to 800,000 years.
They have thousands of oak or thousands
of earthquakes in Yellowstone every year.
Thousands.
Like little rumbles.
The comedian earthquake was at the
comedy store last week. It's funny, Dude.
So funny dude. He's a good dude too.
Yeah, it's a really friendly guy.
One of the coolest stories like that.
I mean, he's one of the coolest,
not completely mainstream
famous comedians I know of.
And I remember working the
door at the comedy store.
He was pretty famous 10 years ago.
I guess you're just white.
I mean I guess I don't,
black community earthquake is a
monster in the black community.
That's different and people are
laying, let's just face it. Exactly.
Mandy white people laugh at earthquake.
Yeah.
In the point is it's like I didn't know
about him until I was a door guy at the
store and then all of a sudden somebody
is like earthquakes popping in and
popping of the comedy store.
If you don't know like there's already
a set lineup so you have to be like
Onstar,
like a Dave Chappelle comes in or Seinfeld
or like the pop and in it's somebody
who's like earthquakes popping in. I'm
like, what the fuck is an earthquake?
That man though,
the guy literally got that
name from because like they
said that when he used to
perform in Atlanta and he hit the ground
shape.
Gee, what a beast. He's like a
black Joey Diaz sort of laser.
He's a very wise, he's a very,
very funny dude and you know,
earthquake is, he's been around man.
He's been killing for a long time.
I couldn't, I just, there's nothing more
fun than finding out those three kids.
No. About, you know, what else is cool
meeting him. He's a nice guy. Yeah.
That's nice.
When you run into someone like an
earthquake or someone that you respect to
think they're really funny and they're
cool as fuck too. That's, you know,
one of the nicest things.
And that's one thing,
like comedians that don't have other
comedian friends are always so weird to me
because I only know a few of them,
but they're so weird.
A handful of non comedian friends and
I see them very rarely and it's fun.
I mean, we have fun, but I mean,
I really can't let her rip on us.
It's a comedian,
the one that's having fun and fucking
working a lot, you know what I mean?
No, I do know what you mean. But I,
I have a lot of friends that are comedians
because I feel like it balances me
out a little bit.
Yeah.
You're like a real super human that you
have like hunting buddies and shit and I
don't have that
pro wrestling,
my hunting buddies or some of my
favorite friends. Yeah, they uh,
they experience hunting buddies
or some of my favorite friends.
That's how small bite my,
like John Dudley.
Yeah. Rebuts yeah, the rivets. Yeah.
They're really good people. Man.
My friend Adam Green tree from Australia.
Fun with him when I was there. Yeah.
Yeah. We had a good time up there, man
in Melbourne. God Damn, that was fun.
Adam Green trees, the salt of the earth,
but it's like all those guys are, um,
they've experienced like intense
form of life and adversity.
They're hunters and their bow hunters,
which is even more intense.
Like guys like Dudley and guys like Cam,
like they're not,
they don't have like a
chip on their shoulder.
They don't have to prove themselves
to anybody. They're out there.
They're trying to do better for themselves
and better at this really difficult
thing. I was thinking about that man
was like, I'm wearing this shirt today.
She was sure tomorrow.
This is a Eastman's
bowhunting shirt they sent me.
It's a bowhunting magazine and I'm a
podcast Eastman's elevators as podcasts
that I listen to on bow hunting.
And I was thinking about it like these
people that pursue it the way this guy
from the Eastman elevated
podcast name is Bryan Barney,
or the way Cam Haynes does it, or the way
John Dudley does it, or Adam Green tree,
they're like, it's, it's not
just like they're hunters.
They're also like athletes.
Like there's,
this is a very difficult pursuit.
It's not what everybody thinks is like,
it's not just simple as finding
an animal shooting with an Arrow,
like getting to the position where
you can shoot an animal with an arrow.
You have to be physically fit.
It's hard to do.
You've got to get up a giant fucking hill.
You got to be able to get there in time.
You gotta be patient,
you've got to be knowledgeable. You
gotta be quiet, you got to be stealthy.
You gotta be skillful.
You gotta be able to handle pressure.
You gotta be able to handle your nerves
when you're ready to make this shot.
On an animal's life with a bow and arrow.
There's a lot of shit going on, man.
You gotta be safe.
You're up in the mountains by yourself.
You've gotta be aware of,
there's predators out there
like real mountain lions,
bears. You're running into grizzlies
knew what I was thinking the other day.
How do you guys eat when you're out
there and bring food? They bring food.
Like sandwiches. No, you bring,
well there's one company that I
actually had the owner on my podcast.
Uh, God damn it. What the
fuck is Chris's last name?
I got to, I got to Google his
last name now because if I don't,
I'm going to feel mad at myself.
But he's got this company
called green belly meals.
Was
this the smell? Is the smell
of the food? Make more animals?
No,
I mean it can shit.
Now I feel like I have to
log on and find his name.
Maybe I'll have it on this.
Um,
anyway, I forget his last name. I
Apologize Dude. You're a good guy.
I don't mean to diss you life.
Forgetting your name.
He wrote a book too on
the Appalachian Trail.
I just had a mom such a fucking space
cadet. The problem is in the morning.
Tell me if you feel like this when you
have to get up early in the morning and
like take a flight.
My brain literally works on
like 30% of its capacity.
Yeah.
We're built like our brains are supposed
to turn on and we have something.
I'm going to find him in my
little podcast list here.
You got a in here? Yeah, no, I'm
just fucking stupid dude. Yeah,
I remember when I said that Rumble
Johnson knocks airplanes out of the hair.
Yeah.
Okay. Chris cage. That's
his name. Sorry Chris. Um,
yeah, it happens. You fuck up. But
my point being he makes us, uh,
he makes these meal bars called
green belly meal bars and uh,
they're super dense.
You have one packet,
it's one third of your
nutritional requirements.
Really heavy in calories and like
you want to take stuff like that,
stuff that's dance,
like take people,
take a lot of almond butter and
peanut butter, like healthy fats. Um,
there's a company that I really liked
called phat fudge and they make uh, this,
this woman,
she makes a Mary,
she makes these little packets
and they're like Paleo Fudge.
It's got MCT oil in it and raw
cocoa and it's really good for you.
It's Matt again,
like real healthy.
You want to take things that are like
real calorie dense cheese is good.
I'm like Salamis good. Some people
like to take candy bars. They like,
like some simple sugar,
like if they're really crashing to pick
them back up because the demands are
like pretty extreme and the
demands of on your body.
And I think that's one of the things that
people underestimate when you're going
like 12,000 feet elevation,
13,000 feet elevation,
the air's super thin. You're
carrying a pack. If you have a rifle,
the rifles having you're in, you're
hiking and you're going up these steep,
steep hills and you're doing it for many,
many miles to try to get into
position where if the animals are,
and if your bow hunting,
you know you,
you've got to do that and then you
have to draw your bow back and steady
yourself and execute a shot. When you're
holding your boasts like it's difficult,
you're holding it freehand, it a rifle,
at least you could rest on something,
you know,
you can rest it on the raw log and all
you have to do is just squeeze slowly and
evenly and pull the trigger.
You're so much more of a man than I am.
I use all the cheat codes
on grand theft auto.
I don't even know who my way through
the missions on that. I just,
well did you do stand up and stand up
as one of the hardest things for your
brain that you could do as far as like
dealing with pressure and this is coming
from someone who is now I know you,
you wrestled in high school so he had
some one on one competition that was nerve
wracking when you were young and you know,
and I did a little bit of wrestling
in high school and then I,
I fought in martial arts tournaments
for a long time and all those things are
scary and nerve wracking.
But comedy is almost ask area at least
was like doing it the first time.
I was so scared the first time I did it.
And you do that,
you push yourself. I mean, you know
what I mean? Like we do, it never ends.
I mean there's nights probably tonight
when the lineup ends up falling,
how it falls.
I'm going to be run at one 15
whatever ends up happening.
I'm going to be, it is a
fight. Last week, you know,
last week I remember I had my best
Tuesday spot in my life and it was like,
you know, 11:00 PM or something like
that. Kevin Hart pops and doesn't hour.
I end up judging gross battles to be
popped in and doing an hour an hour on a
pop band,
which is just a devastating blow.
That means that everybody,
including myself,
is going on an hour later,
plus audiences drained extra dream from
watching one person do an hour when the
rest of the show was fundamentally
cut up for 15 minutes.
That alone makes it a drag,
like,
yeah, that's interesting. I didn't
know guys. We're doing that now.
I didn't know they're allowing
guys to do a whole hour.
It's on that weird,
you know,
really shouldn't do that though. Oh,
I agree. That fucks with the lot.
If it's a regular night, was it a regular?
Is Tuesdays? I was just saying. Yeah.
Yeah, that's, that's not really that cool
because like it's cool that he comes in,
that's for sure. Cool. But a whole hour.
Well that's a part of the word Tommy.
People Thought Tommy was insane back in
the day because he would literally go,
oh, thank you. What are you crazy?
You think he's been with an hour here?
This is Mitsis club.
You know when he was nuts with that shit,
I think he was probably the only one
that would, uh, talk to people like that.
Dude, I'm going to paint, so we're
going to pause this. I know folks.
I never pee during podcasts by surprise.
She been drinking a lot of water.
I'm trying to hydrate myself more
and it's right now it's a problem.
So we were looking right back. All
right, we're back, ladies and gentlemen.
You know what technology where they really
been slacking is in the innovation of
make an airline. Bathrooms
not smell like poop. Yeah.
It always smells like poop.
Specifically poop. Yeah,
because someone's pooping into a hole
in the ground and it's not even really a
toilet bowl. It's not wishy washy
water. Here's you plop in a log,
write down on the aluminum siding.
It's like if you were doing like,
like it's like those Koala daycare
things where you pull the table down.
Oh yeah. Eating breakfast stuff.
Morning airport restaurants.
Like in people love pooping on flights
by the way. It's like, it's like,
well, they get nervous. It's people
get nervous, they have to poop.
There's people like,
you know the seatbelt sign goes off
and a guy just goes and takes a dump.
It's like going to Vegas,
Bro. It's like a 35 minutes.
You can't hold on where people were
already making our descent and you have to
go take a shit right now. Some
people can't, man. Some people can't.
These virgin stewardesses are
always like very flirtatious
by the flirting with you.
Well not this one,
but the one on the flight out here
you liked or didn't you loved her?
You did. Didn't you heard some ladies
that are not urgent, urgent at all?
Beat up. How dare you? She
went home and have a good way.
You stumbled on the word virgin and you
tried to recover like something extra
hard. Turn off. The TV is upset
that I'm talking about this.
She's like returned DRC time.
Stop Talking Shit About,
Oh, you're done like me. What? You
like to go from the other flights.
Yeah. Um, anyway, Texas
is a bad ass place,
isn't it? Yeah. I love
doing chosen Dallas.
I'd been having so much
fun this year in Texas.
I've already been here a few times back
and forth. Austin, Houston, Dallas,
one of the best comedies,
dates in the country. No doubt.
I never been to San Antonio. I heard.
That's great too. A lot of guys like work.
I was just there in January.
You got to take all my buddies.
We went to the royal rumble because
a lot of fun. We ran into Ron White,
some lady showed up on a
Saturday night at the club.
We had just gotten to the club.
Some lady comes up to me, he goes,
you're Tony Hinchcliffe, Huh? And
I'm like, uh, yeah. She's like,
I have a message from Mr
Rod wipe and I'm just like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
This mother fucker sent a human being.
That's how big of a baller Ron white is.
He sent a real life human being,
not a text, not a memo,
not a letter. A lady,
Ron White ones to invite you to hang
out with him. You and your friends.
Come on over.
We're all gonna meet at this bar after
he's done with his show and after you're
done with yours.
And I'm like it for that isn't some Texas
powerful son a human being like that's
like sending a raven,
right? Yeah. Better than a raven.
Yeah. It's better than a raven.
Raven. Yeah. Ron White's a bad mother
fuckers. Guys on tour bus. Yeah.
He's got his own Tequila. Yeah. Ron
White's man. It's got its own Tequila son.
That's crazy. My Mom's
comedian. It's mother's Day.
That's awesome. It is mother's Day, right?
Shout out to the moms hollow and all
the ladies out there getting knocked up.
Oh yeah. Holla. Making babies strong.
Thank you to all the chicks out there.
Loved Dick. That's how you make people.
Yeah.
Even if you're a woman that loves vagina,
shout out to you too.
Shout out.
Shout out to all lesbians.
It's an amazing that that's like that.
People are so jealous that we
don't like a girl likes Dick.
I like you should like a girl likes
Dick Cause this isn't that like like you
want, but no really you really what
you want is her to like you're a Dick,
right? No other decks don't want
her to just like Dick and general,
those girls are problematic,
but it's,
it's commonly understood
that all guys love sex.
Like they were all guys
love Pussy, right? Yeah.
You only supposed to love like
one kind of guy or one girl. Yeah.
But guys are disgusting. Whereas girls,
it's thought of like to be virtuous.
You're like one day maybe try one out
and you don't like it anymore and you get
a new one but one on death
can't just love deck. Yeah.
Yeah.
That's just too many people as it is.
You got love that.
Do you know how bad people must've
loved Dick back on people, Diane?
Like all the time,
like nobody lived
and when there was nothing else going on.
Oh,
nothing to do other than this one fun
stick attached to you in the front of your
body.
And no one would tell you that you're
not supposed to fuck cause it was wasn't
even a language yet. Yeah, you
would just fuck everybody is fuck.
And then you wash your friends get
eaten by Jaguars in front of you.
Yeah.
Make
babies together.
Your month intense.
A baby must have been
before they new language.
It's just you and you're smart and you
have a, do you think, here's the question,
how smart where Hillman's
or modern humans,
when they came up with the first noises
that meant things like ditch chimps.
Do that now, do you think, do you
think they have noises for shit?
Like they must right,
like certain noises for stuff.
I think it all comes to like animalistic
stuff. Right? So like if
yeah. Oh yeah.
And then like you hear that noise,
it's like, oh that always means snake.
I'm sure I'm almost positive I read
something like that, that they uh,
they did that with certain monkeys.
They had certain sounds they
interpreted after a while.
Like they do this sound always
when an eagle's nearby. Like,
have you ever seen those Harpy Eagles
in Venezuela? You know what that is?
It's a monkey. Neagle
Bro. A monkey, a monkey.
Eaton Eagle. I love to eat monkeys
and ego that Oh yes they do.
It's one of the things they found
about some of the early humans. Um,
when they found fossils
and skulls and shit,
they found that the inside of
the skull had been scraped,
which there was some speculation that
maybe it was tools and sometimes they
looked at the scraping on.
This one looks like a raptors claw and
they think it was people that had gotten
killed by Egos make that early human
beings were prey to a larger birds.
Yeah. Particularly this one in New
Zealand that they know existed, you know.
So there's all this speculation about
like how many different birds existed and
you know,
we have like a pretty good fossil record
of really big eagles and these things
called terror birds at eight
people and shit like that.
But they think back on when
we were like smaller monkey,
like things that we probably got
jacked by eagles man. Especially,
there was a Haast eagle that lived in
New Zealand alongside people for sure.
Because I think they made it
extinct just thousands of years ago,
like 14,000 years ago or something.
I might be wrong about the number,
but it was a huge eagle that had
like a 10 foot 11 foot wingspan
and they aid people.
If births could talk, if
Burt's could talk, they would
just take shit over. Oh God.
You realize that if bird's somehow like
learn how to talk today. Two are big.
Yeah. They would just take everything
over. Fuck your computer. Mine.
Now we have guns. You, I'm
still have guns. They're birds,
but guns change everything and
you're in one of those tanks with a slot
and you got the machine gun out there
and you're just blasting them out of
the sky. A gun only has one barrel.
Birds can attack from
multiple angles at once.
Yeah, that's true. At least 60 attack,
but you hide in a tank and
you shoot him out of the sky.
They don't play that dude tanks.
Yeah. They don't feel like that.
They'll stay above and they'll
let you run out of your artillery.
If they were smart enough to talk,
then they'd be smart enough
to let you run out of bullets.
Right?
Like what if they had hands along with
the wings and the grab gravity tank,
the flag out of the tank.
It's me talking bird.
They would do what they do
with like goats. How Eagles,
Greg goats and they throw him off cliffs.
Yeah.
That's cold blooded shit
early is they drag them off,
thrown them to their death. Like
they know what they're doing. Yeah.
That's mean to ruthless animal,
man.
It's a fascinating animal.
But so you think that uh,
those things preyed on people like
early humans, they found these skulls.
The inside of them were all
scraped out. Scary. Ooh,
dog. Just, there's
something about birds, man.
They just so they don't
give a fuck about you.
Like if you look at a dog or even a cat,
a cat at least per hours and looks at you
and like likes that you petting it and
it's like an interaction
between you and the cat.
Right? The affects us. We're
on the same level. Yeah, man.
You look in the Eagle's eye, you're like,
why am, why am I keeping you alive? Right.
Crazy comp. But I didn't know I was
looking at us salsa. Yeah, exactly.
And they're looking at us like,
why do you guys just stay on this floor?
Why don't you guys, when you guys
flap your arms, you fucking idiot.
You guys can move them around.
You just down here like prey,
right?
Can you just sit here on this level?
I think about what an eagle can do.
It's,
it's swoops down and scoops of
fish out of a fucking river,
a big one and carries it away.
Grabs a fish.
No fucking strong. You have to be
to grab a salmon with your hands.
Talons. It's sink into it. He
just carries it off flying.
That's,
that's an Sushi.
Oh my God. What a ruthless
bird. Crazy. It's kind of nuts.
That's our national bird too.
Somebody didn't want it to be,
uh,
was it Ben Franklin? I think
thought it was like a punk ass bird.
You said? That's a fungus ass bird. He
had like reasons for it. I read it last.
Why he has an eagle whiny. Can't
remember whether it was him, John Adams,
Jefferson, one of those weird old guys.
But like they're like fuck the eagle.
How could use fuck the Eagle? They are
so hungry for it. They're gangster,
but it's like they're also a,
I wish I could remember what it was.
I think it was like he didn't like,
like how they like squawk cause like
they caught him like squat the or
something. You don't want that.
You don't need that squawky bird.
Then you really should it be an eagle
though. We're America, which are really,
really,
what's the truly the most truly
angels are pretty bad ass word. A brass
bird rather. Yeah, but it's still a bird.
Well there's no, what about the
shark? We should be a puppy.
Yeah. So, well sneaky. We don't have to
be some killer murderous thing. Right.
I love that.
I can be,
it'd be something cute to the
fucks you up some of the youtube,
like a snapchat filter that's, we are
one of those puppies. It's cartoon ones.
Little dog ears and nose.
What happened instead of having like
a mascot that's an actual animal,
have a fake
one. Like a, like a team. Teams
have a gopher that wears a tie.
That's telling me US three. Your College
football team. Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
We'd be a mascot. Yeah. You know,
I mean the whole idea of having a mass
guys kind of crazy, isn't it? Yeah.
A national animal. We have a
were the blues, Merck Eagle.
Just colds doing run bro.
Yeah. The whole thing is weird.
It's like we have a birth weight
but we're a bird where bird. Okay.
And Russia is a bear. Okay, we're, we'll,
we'll, we're fucked. I have news for you.
Bears and eagles. I'll fucking blow my
money on the bear all day long. Yeah.
That's a lot of good.
But that's not a good deal
for sure.
The,
I wonder if the other countries look
at us like we're morons for that.
Like is Afghanistan here that we have
like represent this eagle and they're just
like,
what are they doing?
Don't you think that other
countries have an animal too?
No,
I think other countries,
some people just like there,
they don't even have anything.
There's comprehending of
our silly shit that we do.
Oh, cool. Yeah.
Do you know that the Mississippi
state flag still has confederate flag?
Yes. I wanted to do this this last
night when the guy from Jackson,
Mississippi within the
two white trash guys spot
like trash guys and you
know who I'm talking about.
They literally listen to own
it. First of all, how dare you,
Jason Knight and Chaz Kelly,
I was with the guy
from Jackson, Mississippi. His
whole family was in the audience,
her family and friends and they were
all wearing the same shirt. Yeah.
And I just thought it
was the confederate flag.
I didn't realize that it was the
Mississippi state flag and they were going
fucking crazy.
Like they were the craziest patch of
people in the whole arena last night.
Literally they had a whole
section that was insane.
And I, he ended up saying to, uh,
the sound guy who I was sitting next to,
I'm like,
look at these crazy people. They have
the confederate flag on their shirt.
And he's like, oh no, that's just a the
Mississippi state flag, and I'm like,
oh wow.
I didn't know that I'm a complete idiot.
I thought they were just going to
fucking burn a cross in victory up there.
Like they seemed like
they were the [inaudible]
party.
Do you think that people
know that Mississippi has
a confederate flag it state
flag? I didn't know how many people do
think like outside of Mississippi are even
aware of that.
I would probably guess
if you and I don't know,
then I would guess somewhere in like
the 10% I would say three to 5%.
I think 10% is very giving.
Wow. How did they not know that people
right now are screaming, you're idiots.
Everybody knows.
Yeah. If you know that, then I'm, you
live in one of the two really lit,
one interlocking,
stayed away from Mississippi.
If you know that or you're one of
those people that really got into the
confederate flags origins when they
pulled it off the general lead or are you
memorized overall? Just state
flags. In which case, Whoa,
this is the wiser.
Your hobbies are out of control,
but when they pulled that state flag or
they pull the confederate flag rather
off the general Lee,
they pulled generally off if they don't
have the Dukes of Hazzard on TV land
anymore because of that flag,
which I found fascinating man,
like for years and years and years.
And I'm not saying I'm not against
the idea of pulling the show,
I understand the sentiment behind it that
in their eyes that's a racist symbol.
But it's just fascinating
to me just purely from like
just an observers point of
view. Like, oh look at how
the culture is shifting.
Like we used to be able to have this
on TV and no one said a word about it.
It was on the roof of a car
that was on television and the,
the car was arguably one of the big stars
of the show because like you got cards
from Bach, it's hot as fuck. You got the
daisy dukes. Yeah. You got the doors.
Yeah. And then you got a Bo and
Luke Duke, right? They're the stars.
And then you've got the fucking car,
man. Wait, what was the cops theme? Uh,
well there was Roscoe p
Coltrane, boss Hog, right.
Boss Hog and Roscoe p Coltrane.
Right. That's all I remember.
Ross boss Hog and Roscoe was a
sheriff. Right? I guess I said No.
Who was the sheriff? But he, he was the
mayor. Mayor boss Hog, right. Wasn't he?
There was a sheriff Roscoe p Coltrane,
I of don't remember.
And then there was Cletus who
was in love with daisy Duke.
I remember when they made the movie with
Johnny Knoxville and Jessica Simpson.
And of course I don't remember that.
Nobody saw, I don't remember that.
I literally don't remember that.
That movie was so bad.
It got the TV show canceled.
Two Jessica Simpson was hot as
the sun at one point in time
at one point.
Now Lisa Simpson,
uh, why I'm on it. Don't
homer Simpson might be the greatest
character and the history of television
probably. Cause cause he's so card too.
It was right up there with a cart. Ma'Am.
Carbon might be as well. Yeah.
They're almost like, but homer,
he's like the ultimate
buffoons and he's immortal.
And you didn't do anything to them.
All right.
It's interesting him in Cartman both
don't edge and sorta troublemakers.
Very stubborn.
It's very much the American way.
I mean it's just like imagine that
and imagine that homer Simpson adopted
Cartman like that's a movie.
Wow, that's another great idea.
Another one,
homer Simpson adopts carbon.
He dated
two totally different
styles, but in, you know,
it's like you got your king of the
hill style of a animated comedy.
You've got F F is for family is
coming out soon to season two.
I bet that's going to be killer as a funny
show, man. That's a really funny show.
You don't really watch comedy shows.
I'm looking forward to the return of
house of cards and the return of game of
Thrones.
Uh, I watched, uh, efforts for
family. It's legitimately funny, Dude.
It's a legitimately funny show. But
uh, yeah, I'm looking forward to that.
I gave up on game of Thrones.
I mean that game of Thrones walking dead.
So when I gave up on walking dead,
I created some space that house of cards
filled feel much better about myself.
I can't deal with zombies anymore.
I'm with you buddy. I'm going to do,
zombies are dead to me. Literally
you just, after awhile I was like, okay,
this isn't, this can't go anywhere. Yeah.
Like when the sales nation rebuild,
when do you dummies kill all these armies.
What are these zombies eating?
How this thing alive?
How they here for so long or you just,
how come they're not just
skeletons now they stopped riding.
They brought for years. Oh, they just rot
fears. How about fuck you. Yeah. What?
Are you not making any sense anymore?
Yeah. You should all be dead.
It should be gone.
I never got into the walking dead.
I'm not in any of that stuff. I can't.
They violate physics. Yeah, did violate
nature. It's not just that it's a Zombie.
It doesn't rot away. We talk to them.
It doesn't rot away. It's dead. Come on.
You told me that the dead.
Right.
So how come it doesn't like
in the beginning of the show,
like at the beginning seasons
they had like more shit going on.
You know,
like I remember when they had to blow up
that building that had the anti Zombie
Shit in it where they created the Zombie
in the first place and there was a guy
and his wife turned the whole deal. That
was, that was the walking dead. Right.
It just was, I don't remember in the
beginning it was just better. Yeah.
It was just, it seemed like
it was interesting. And then
after a while, like, oh,
I get it, it's always going to suck.
Look, your life always gonna suck.
It's gonna suck here that
it's gonna suck there.
And then this guy is going to get killed,
the baseball bat and this person's
going to turn into a Zombie.
You're going to have to watch this
person get torn apart. Okay, I get it.
You just fucking with me.
It doesn't really.
Meanwhile,
those game of Thrones guys are taking
literally just blowing our minds. Yeah.
And as his house of cards.
Yeah.
How's the cards is crazy
because they were like,
they were really giving us an,
even though it's obviously fiction,
I feel like they're giving us a real
window on sort of house stuff does work in
a weird way, even though
again, it's fiction.
Like did they just show you how people
communicate with one another to get what
they want?
They show you what politics is,
how you can use that in your everyday
life. But it's just that business, I mean,
they are in the business of
like being shady to one another.
That's what it is. It's a weird field.
It's crazy. Very bizarre industry.
Almost all gossip, drama and lying to
people and knowing people favors, yeah.
By powers and politics and all that
stuff that we see on a daily basis in the
real world. It's just like they're doing
a fictional account of it. Exaggerated.
It is.
Yeah.
I was just going to say, you can tell
that they're doing the research. Yeah.
You could tell that a lot of that's real.
And
I mean they definitely push,
right.
The pushes the boundaries is pushing
people on to change reps. Yeah.
But, um, they're definitely colluding,
colluding with,
you know,
the press and leaking things and trading
favors and I think it's a lot of why
shit so goddamn stagnant.
If the Republicans or the Democrats
10 favors and the Democrats or the
Republicans and pavers and
what the fuck are we doing?
Yeah, it's all weird, but uh, it's,
it's a system that's been around for a
long time and it just never been exposed
in a drama the way it's been
on this show and this show,
like they go so deep with it and
obviously the bunch of crazy shit murders,
all the studies show
look, but who knows, man,
you look at some of the stuff that the
Clintons were accused of and some other
presidents are accused of and look at
the Kennedy assassination when who the
fuck knows what's really going on
behind the scenes with these people?
They definitely are colluding
on some things, you know,
they're definitely talking
and coordinating things and
they're strategizing and
they definitely have plans. It's just to
what, what extent does it really go? No,
another great show that I can't wait for
it. I don't know. When it comes back,
the stranger things on Netflix.
Did you watch that season?
I just watched episode one.
I'm not really into like aliens.
Oh dare you like pro wrestling and
not like aliens. You son of a bitch.
Really different things.
Yeah. One of them wrestling
aliens.
Are you telling me you're not into
seeing this new Ripley Scott alien movie
that's coming out? Rip Late. Ridley Scott
Rather. Oh, said Ripley's car. I saw that.
The preview for that the other night.
I do want to see the good Lord that
looks good and what they can do now with
special effects.
Make things way more terrifying.
That hasn't always been my favorite
science fiction franchise I bought.
I mean there was a couple of them.
They were a little lame,
but I'm a giant fan of that.
That creature,
what do they call the Xena form? Sina
more Xena more? Is that what they call it?
I think it was.
I thought it was just called the alien.
I think they called it the xenomorph.
I forgot. Maybe I'm making that up,
but I think that's what it is,
but it's that that is just the
most terrifying alien ever,
just as vicious insect,
like thing that
grows to full size and like a few days.
That's totally possible to man.
It's totally possible.
So we'd have to get some food though.
That's the only thing that
I didn't like about that.
Like how's it growing without food?
Yeah.
I mean it has to be eating those people.
Okay,
but how many people does it eat to get
to be 700 pounds or whatever it was?
It seems like it would have to eat 700
pounds of the people to even get in the
ballpark or 700 pounds.
Yeah. Where do they,
did it come on it's own ship. It
came for the dude's chest, remember?
Yeah. He grabbed a hold of
his face and it makes it suck.
It's little alien Dick.
And it comes in its stomach and it makes
a person inside your body and it blows
out your chest.
Remember that coming back to the face,
grabs it with his hand and
then a literally like an
alien tentacle Dick Thing
comes out of the palm
and just mouth fucks you.
Oh God.
It's a great ending.
A great animal.
Like as far as like something that
someone created to terrify you,
it's an amazing being,
you know?
I mean I think it's the best alien
science fiction creation and also it's HR
Geiger's like design.
So his design was so freaky
and dark and twisted.
Like it was a,
it was like the creature of the
black lagoon meets like the wiring,
the of the Millennium Falcon meet me.
It's almost like a semi mechanical
looking and insect like,
but also like kinetic.
It looks like it has muscles and it looks
just like it would just rip you apart
man. It looks terrifying.
Giant head of it. Yeah.
This is scary shit up.
The fact that it's,
it's blood as Amanda and an acid.
I mean come on son.
That that animal thing,
that alien being is the coolest creation
I think in all of science fiction.
And this, this is Nick's
this week, man. This Friday.
My dark is on full pointe right now.
Full Scifi Dork.
Can we see movies?
Do you actually go to the movie theater?
Like a normal human being ever?
The fuck you talking about blaming here,
Joe Rogan. I mean, I
don't know how that works.
Do you live right next
to you on a normal plane?
I go to normal restaurants with you.
I do shit with you all at
this isn't a normal planes.
When I'm by myself I'm not flying
this plane. It's still a plane.
But yeah, no, the movie theater
like everybody else man.
So like you're going to go see
alien with like a friend or,
okay. Are you, do you
want to go on a date?
Is that what you're doing or you're
beating around the Bush and then I'm just
curious like I can't really, I just
go to the movies, go to the movies.
Like buy a ticket, go to the movies. No.
Well the friend Jesus Christ,
I wouldn't go by myself.
That's a little rough. That's
weird. She went by herself.
People would like stare at you. Hey man,
chill. Rob Has got no friends like, hey,
I got friends. Just no one's, no one's
available right now. Okay. This is,
this time was convenient for me.
Yeah.
It's like watching a movie at
home by herself. Totally normal.
Going to the movies by yourself. Ooh,
I've done that before on the road though.
And it's awesome because you actually
get to enjoy the movie. Yeah.
People going to a movie with
people can only be a distraction.
I think I've only gone to the movies by
myself and then may less than maybe six
times ever in my whole life,
but they're good trips.
I live right next to a
Tarantino's movie theater.
Really cool movies.
They're like,
they just had the 25th anniversary of
reservoir dogs this past month and they
played it every night at midnight
for like two weeks. And um,
that helps my point.
Oh yeah.
I don't mind going and checking
out a movie by myself at all.
What I ate is going with someone that
has a fucking bag of candy that they keep
digging into and shit or
crunch crunch and like,
I know it's like a cheesy subject,
but how popcorn became a movie theater.
Food makes zero sense of it.
It's one of the smelliest foods is
one of the weirdest sounding foods.
Makes people dig in.
It's too much.
It makes a mess.
There's like a list of a laundry
list of complaints about popcorn.
Yeah.
It's definitely not a quiet food.
It kind of turns and when you get
it in a bag, that's the worst.
Someone's ruffling their bag around
or plastic. Anything in plastic.
We got to dig into the plastic
crackle, crackle, crackle.
All those bags are too loud.
The reeses pieces bag,
they make it so that you break
it open trying to open it.
It's at the reasons pcs fly everywhere.
No,
they know and then you
have to buy you back here.
That's the dumbest conspiracy or pcs
or pieces you call it Reese's pieces.
Reese's pieces, Reese's pieces. It's not,
it's not reeses pcs.
It's Reese's pieces.
See this is one of the great conundrums.
It's like the Berenstain bears.
Yeah, sorry. It's confusing it.
You think it's one thing, but
it's really another thing. Okay,
well what are the peanut butter cups?
Reese's Reese's peanut butter cups.
R. E. E. S. E. Reese. Lisa's. Yeah.
I think maybe
it's,
I know I have a thing.
It was definitely always
receipts when I was growing up.
I feel like maybe I'm wrong.
Well, people get used to saying
shit wrong. Like in Texas,
they say especially that's a big
thing that people say instead of,
especially x especially. Oh Wow. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't, it's like there's
an x in there. They'll say, well,
y'all is expecially need to worry
about that. [inaudible] spatially.
It's a beautiful accent.
Texas people are truly, I was just gonna
say that might be my favorite accent.
They're just so cool. Even when I
disagree with someone from Texas,
like one time,
uh,
one time a cop tried to arrest me
and my buddy Matt at a Whataburger,
this is like eight years ago and
we didn't know why he wanted he,
he's like, you guys need to get out of
this. What a burger. It was like 3:00 AM.
It was our first time in a water burger
ever. We had just placed our order.
I just handed the cashier a $5 bill.
I'll never forget it in a sheriff,
comes over my shoulder and he goes,
you and your friend need to get out
of here. I'm like, really? What?
Cut To our other buddy.
Uh,
other comedian gets in trouble
for defending us. It's like,
you can't kick my friends out and stuff
first trip on a water or where are you
kicking them out of here? And the
cop's like, don't worry about it.
And cut to the next day.
Our buddy who ended up spending a
little bit of time in jail that night
defending us.
Me and my,
my other little la friend
got to leave the Whataburger,
but our buddy from Texas got in trouble
or buddy from Texas the next day as his
friend who's the chief of police on
speaker phone and we're sitting in the car
traveling back to California and
he's like, dude, so what happened?
What happened buddy? You know, and the
head chief of police literally goes,
uh,
yeah,
the cop told me that you are defending
your friends that appears is of low.
According to this officer,
a couple of faggots were five metal
water burger or something like that.
And me and my buddy were the obviously
a couple of faggots in this story.
We started dying of laughter.
I mean dying of laughter.
But with that said,
the guy with this Texas accent, you can
tell he's wearing like a cowboy hat,
chief of police,
a couple of faggots by metal water burger.
And me and my buddy were having like
a flight argument at the time, like,
you know about whatever it was.
We weren't,
obviously we weren't fighting was me
and Matt Edgar Wright, a California kid.
That's hilarious. I have a water. Thank
you. Awesome dude. That's hilarious.
So the cop was just being
homophobic. Totally. Oh,
so will you guys joking
around about stuff?
Yeah, we were literally having
some like play fight about like,
like it was like a play argument about,
I can't remember who knows a lot,
you know, literally a couple La
comedians excited to be on the road.
Probably opening for free
for who we were working with.
That is so funny.
So you were just basically being comedians
and being loud and they decided you
were two gay guys in the middle
of a spat. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Well there's definitely that in Texas too.
Like in the south in general.
Like I had some friends that moved to
Nashville from La Love Nashville too.
I do too. But they had this idea
that they were gonna, you know,
they're going to be in Nashville and
nationals, all open mind and artists.
And she said like right around like the
third or fourth time I heard the word
nigger and I was like,
oh, okay. This is like,
there's some outlying areas that you're
in a mall Walmart an hour away from
Nashville and you hear that kind
of talk and you're like, okay,
I'm still in Tennessee
like this, you know? Ooh.
But I at least they know what have a
confederate flag on their tee shirts,
but Jesus Christ.
But I mean,
like the way that that cop called
us a couple of couple of faggots,
it's like, I believe that,
wow, this convinced me,
I guess Texas.
I'm a faggot
in California. I'm Tony.
I wonder if that's like,
where are you where you were in
Houston, right? Uh, doing that. Well,
that was like eight or nine years
ago. That was in Corpus Christi. Okay.
But I don't think that would happen
in the Austin now. Yeah, no. Yeah.
Austin has got it. It's
more progressive. Yeah.
Austin is a total livable place.
Yeah.
Like it would be a nice place to live.
You would enjoy it there.
When we do shows there, man, they like
particularly epic shows. Oh my God, yes.
The cap city. Yeah, man. Yeah.
Cap City's amazing. Uh, Austin city
limits that theater there. That's amazing.
Yeah. There's a, it's a special
place, man. In my eyes in Texas,
it's a different spot.
It's like it's more rowdy than
a lot of places in the country,
but it's also a friendly, yep. It's
got a lot of like good qualities.
Like a happy I lightness to it.
Yeah.
It's like they greet you at the
front of the store when you walk in,
but they also make sure
you're not stealing anything.
Yeah. Now it's like, yeah,
it's just a little more
extreme on both levels. Yeah.
But then there's like so much space to
like what you're talking about is just
the cities and what's
interesting he has to,
cities are just a small percentage of
this monstrous landmass that's known as
Texas.
You don't realize how big it is until
you have to drive through it and you're
like, oh my God, it tastes
like a day. It's huge.
It's an enormous state. Great
place though. It's crazy.
I'll states have different fields,
man.
They really do like a show in Albany is
just going to be different than a show
in Dallas. It's just going
to be different. It just is.
It's going to be diabolically
worse Albany, New York.
Oh my God. No. Yeah, you
didn't enjoy it up their home.
We never again.
What do you think it is?
You think it's just like a
lack of opportunity up there.
The weather's not so good. Keep
feel trapped. Yup, keep going at it.
You're just getting started.
You call, you're 100% right,
so you could go on and on.
The y is the real question.
Don't you think though that in
Albany? Well, they got stuck there.
They were there from another time.
You know their parents were their parents
parents, but don't you think that like,
Oh God,
here she goes.
Should I pick had that person might be
35 minutes remaining and I went, oh shit.
We be cannot sharpie for the next few
minutes to reach an item to get these
overhead or take care of both your need.
If you have any remaining
just looking at a smiling because
she knows she's on the show. Yeah.
Like she doesn't even know this show is,
I think she was about to plug around
podcasts because I think this going to be
cool because she'll be on a podcast and
she doesn't even know exists. Right.
She'll never find it private. You think
someone or friends will tell her? Maybe.
Maybe.
Um,
but we're bringing this podcast to a,
on a plane down for landing young Tony.
So in conclusion,
crazy ass night of awesome fights.
Steep Emile chick is a bad motherfucker.
Yes. CLEVELAND, Ohio,
Ohio and now a lot of fun people to root
for last night and my people dominated
all the way through everybody that I
picked a one one Yolana is my everything.
I mean we were really
connected during that. Right.
She's your everything like your
love. She's your love. Yeah.
I feel like this is real.
I really want it to be real.
I mean she stops in the middle
of fights and looks over at you.
I'm so glad that you finally started
to notice this because one of the funny
things is I've been sorta telling
you like you thought I was crazy.
Oh No, it's definitely happening
now in a few fights ago,
you literally thought I could tell why
by the way you were those starting with
trolling me. Right. I know
and I don't ever tell you,
but like I'm so glad that you see it.
It's like, to me it's like that
part of teen wolf or Michael J.
Fox goes to his dad and he's like,
damn a werewolf the Werewolf.
But the dad's like,
I'm aware of old to
finally saw it. Like when she was
doing that before the fifth round,
she was just looking at me
pointing right at me and stuff.
And you end DC c me both look back at
me over your right shoulders at the same
time.
Like is this motherfucker?
Yeah, I was not sure if it was you
and I look back on my God damn,
she's pointing right?
We're telling him sit
doing it and she kept looking at me after
each round and everything. And we're,
I feel like we're exchanging energies.
I feel like, I feel like we
need to do a podcast with her.
And then you and her need to go to
dinner. Yeah. Just whatever you do,
don't talk about it on the
internet or, uh, her boyfriend,
we'll find out too late.
I don't care about her boyfriend is a
soccer player from Polish to don't out the
guy. Son of a bitch. So ruthless,
ruthless. Tony Hinchcliffe. Um,
what do you got coming up, man?
You've got some dates.
Huge dates.
Do you want a big tour, right?
Monster Energy outbreak tour.
I'll all of the month of August.
Uh, Nashville, you're like a STD.
Everyone outbreak. Yeah.
The Monster Energy outbreak
is outbreak.
Like a beverage that monster Ng has.
Um, no. If that's the tour
that they do. Oh, they do,
they do with like rappers
and stuff and you know,
monster like doesn't do billboards,
like APP commercials.
They invest in like cool things like the
UFC and like people like learned this
all recently from this whole thing.
So they do this outbreak tour thing,
which they've had some really cool
bands and rappers do and it's been very
successful.
Really.
They do it and they'd be doing it
Fetty wap and the Chainsmokers and
Ben, but I mean, what do they do
when you say they do a tour like a,
did they just put their name
on it? They promote it. Yeah.
Yeah. They do that and it's just a
really cool way of like, you know,
not compromising anything's a integrity
while just being associated with
something that they think is cool.
Right. Yeah. They, they're
in kickboxing to the sponsor.
John Wayne par. Oh, awesome. Yeah. They
sponsor a lot of MMA fighters. Of course.
What I'm really excited
about this tour dates,
it's my first ever like small
theater tour and like rock club tour,
House of Blues and Cleveland Grammer
seat theater in New York City and was
absolutely going everywhere in North
Carolina, Florida. I mean, you name it.
That's dope. Columbus,
Ohio, Cleveland, Akron,
powerful. Tony and Portland. Seattle,
the Aladdin Theater and Portland.
Oh Man. How Fun. It's Portland.
Oh my God. How Fun was for 20
their glass. They chose epic.
That's a real holiday. That became
a holiday during our life. Totally.
Really? During the last
what, 20 years maybe? Yeah,
like nobody used to do for 20 shows,
but just a few years ago I started doing
for 20 shows on April 20th and it's a
holiday man. Yeah, it's a holiday
for us. Like it feels festive.
Like when we go out and we did
those for 20 shows like uh,
last year and this year they feel festive.
Yeah.
Where the fuck did we go last year?
Seattle, Seattle for four 20 last year.
Next year. Probably. Either Denver or
maybe San Francisco. That'll be fun.
Denver might be fun,
but San Francisco gets into,
it might be fun to do it up there.
I'm going to Denver too.
I'm going to absolutely everywhere.
All those seats
available@tonyhinchcliffe.com
Jesus and there's an e on the end
of that. Unlike the picture
that's up at the ice house.
And I have podcasts kill Tony the pony
hour where I interview people and the
store horsemen, which is a
pro wrestling podcast. Oh God,
I hate the name store horseman.
Yeah. That's hilarious then.
But we're all from the comedy store.
I get it. And so these are all, uh,
at Itunes, you get them all on Itunes,
right? Yeah. Glorious. Well Ladies
and gentlemen, we'll bring in
this big bird down to the ground.
Just going to give a shout out
to all the mommies out there.
Cause today's mother's Day and future.
Mommy's to like Yolanda. Yen check.
Are you going to retire? Get a retired
when you knock her up? Yeah. Wow.
We're going to double retire together.
Whoa. You're going to retire to, well,
you're going to be inspired and see every
kid, but yeah, but that savage. Yeah.
Oh God. Yeah. I have to learn
how to fight. I love it.
I'm going to have to learn how to
satisfy a woman and actual woman.
All Right, ladies and gentlemen.
Um, so, uh, one thing that
did happen this week, uh,
Everlast had to cancel something came up
so he won't be on this week and he'll a,
he'll have to reschedule. He's a
busy man, but he's got his, uh, new,
a new project war porn industries,
which is great shit.
You can catch it on youtube. You catch
some of the videos he's played. Well,
actually, no, I don't know
if you can get it on youtube.
I've seen it on Instagram though,
but um,
I think they're trying to figure out how
to distributor out how you can get it.
Um, but they're doing that. That's an
independent project, you know, I like,
I like that music is kind of going along
the same ways that standup is gone.
You know,
they're doing their own shit and they're
trying to do things independently.
I had a Shirley Manson on the other
day from garbage and she was kind of
breaking down the music business and
what it's like and how difficult it is to
make money as a band today.
And how now music companies
these t take everything.
They take a piece of your merchandise.
It take a piece of your live touring,
they'd take a percentage of everything.
Everything you do across the board.
So they do these deals with these artists
or when they distribute their music,
they essentially own a chunk of them and
yeah, they do that and stand up. It's
very weird. How did it go on and stand up?
Stand up. There's this weird
company, you know like,
have you ever heard of like
comedy dynamics? Who does that?
A lot of our friends,
they make a lot of our friends.
What do they do is they distribute.
But what's weird is that they sell it,
which they don't really sell it,
but you need to have some of these
big companies you need to have.
Like it's the most bureaucratic bull
shit you'll ever hear in your life.
You would never put up
with it for a second.
You probably get to bypass it because
you're obviously at the top of the game.
But
like what do you mean they make a deal
where they don't own their specials?
That what you're saying?
We're at least at, first of all, I don't
think they own it forever. Second of all,
I don't think they own the entire thing.
Uh,
but these companies take 20 30% of your
special for absolutely zero reason,
especially, you already have to give what
10% of your manager and this and that,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
Well, I know there was a podcast
production company that uh,
David Taylor and Ari Shapiro had a real
problem with cause they were pitching a
television show and they
created a television show.
They wanted someone to
help them try to sell it.
Like we set something up and these people
apparently wanted a ridiculous amount
of money, like 40% of the show.
And they're like, Whoa, whoa, Whoa,
there's 100% and there's two
of us and you get 40 like,
are you fucking crazy?
Like they wanted more than a third to
just come in and just sort of like help
them negotiate a deal with their products.
I didn't create it hidden, sculpted.
They didn't, they didn't, you know,
you didn't think it through
and do all the work on it.
So people get real squirrely when it
comes to those kind of weird deals where
you're not a content creator, but
you're instead some company. Right?
And there's somebody else that
creates the content. Well,
what's beautiful now it's like guys like
you or me or all these people that do
podcasts, you're all of a sudden your
own content creator and you could,
you don't have to be at,
you don't have to have all these
fucking people in your ear.
You don't have to have everybody
giving you other, okay.
I mean opinion and like special man.
Yeah, the Ice House. That shit's crazy.
Like,
think about a show like,
have you ever done like Cole
bear or one of those shows?
Do you ever done one of those?
When you do,
do those one thing that you do
realize by the way he drank both.
My water's just son of a
bitch. I had one. You had one.
I'll have one right
here. Um, when you, uh,
when you watch those shows,
you see how many people were working
behind the scenes. Like, wait a minute,
hold on. That's one thing that I
noticed when I did, um, that dude's,
what's his name? Bill Russell, the
podcast guy. I did it is HBO show.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
we're just hits him and me sitting down
having a conversation and there was a
Corolla people here,
Mike,
this is essentially like an overstaffed
podcast. No doubt. No doubt.
And because of that, it all
gets like weird. It's all weird.
Yeah. When I made TV shows
man with eyebrows, you know,
it's a major comedy central shows.
And the thing that shocked me the entire
time, and I don't mean slight shock,
I mean sure.
Shock was the amazing
waste of money they have.
They're just throwing money away.
What do you think that is?
They don't know any better or they think
they're on an old Hollywood system.
Right. And when they were coming
up, they were trained that way.
It's like if comedians all,
we're still only focused on getting
five minutes on the tonight show.
That's how I feel like some of those
executives state instead of being like,
what's next? Well, this Netflix thing
we'll never have to worry about that.
I remember,
I remember one exact literally saying,
I'm not kidding you in 2011 we
don't have to worry about them.
We don't have to worry about the Internet.
People always come back to TV.
TV is priceless. They will always come
back. And I remember literally thinking,
I don't know about that,
like watching this
since up until the point where you could
watch the internet on your TV and then
all games are off.
Well, yeah, but then he was also, yes,
but he wasn't saying it like that.
He was saying like,
they're always gonna need TV channels.
Like he was saying like, yeah,
well there's always people like
that, man. I mean there's people
that tell you how to do clean comedy.
There's people that tell you, you
have to do this, you have to do that.
Right.
And they convince themselves and then
all of a sudden they can't even see the
light.
Well,
you remember that girl that
you were dating that was
telling you that you had to
do dark comedy. You should
be all dark. Should actually,
people give shit advice all the time.
They just do.
It's a, it's a real common
thing man. And I don't,
sometimes I wonder if they're
trying to sabotage you or you.
Sometimes when I hear people's
really shitty advice I'm like,
do you really believe this or are you
subconsciously want to sabotage this
person?
Are you like not making sense,
but you're pushing it and
pretending you're making sense.
Like what's really going on here?
Cause this is like your own internal
turmoil bubbling to the surface.
Right.
I think a lot of people,
I think a lot of people want to be given
advice from people they think are smart.
So sometimes they'll get
those people bad advice,
not realizing that we know
it's bad advice, hoping that
we give them good advice.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Maybe like the, you'll correct
them and give them good advice.
I think that some people were
also, yeah. EGOMANIACS yeah.
And they think that they're
right all the time. Yeah.
It's super hard to just step outside of
yourself and look at your own opinions
and look at someone else's opinion
to go, hmm, who's right here.
Cause you automatically want
to pick the year. Right.
So you start out from the
position that you're right.
It's cause we get attached to ideas and
the ideas sort of become a part of you.
They define you.
They're not just an idea,
it's you and your idea all connected.
And that that's a real problem that
a lot of people have with thinking.
I've had it myself and it's something
that I've had to work really hard to push
away to knock out.
You don't thinking and
learning how to think.
It's like one of the weirdest things
because it's one of the most important
parts of life. But it's one of the few
things that we discussed here in school.
Like when you're in school,
you're learning information,
but are you learning how to think?
Are you learning how to be objective?
Are you learning how to look at yourself
and look at your actions and how you
treat others,
how you treat yourself,
and what distractions you're throwing
up in your life in order to deal with
your, uh, uh, you know, like, uh,
especially if you're not getting
things done or you're procrastinating,
you're putting things off.
If you have any addictions
or things along those lines,
you start creating all these problems in
your life to distract yourself with and
they don't teach you about that in school.
It's really interesting.
And they don't teach you a lot of shit,
which is really interesting.
It was just thinking about this last night
while I was smoking weed before going
to bed and I was thinking somebody gave
me a dirty look cause I was blatantly
just smoking a joint. Like it was
a cigarette in front of that hotel.
I don't give a fuck. Right. And
somebody gave me a look like, Eh, Eh,
like that book
Texas, they do that fine. I know
in California nobody gives a shit.
That's why you're used to doing it.
Like if you're hanging out at the comedy
store outside and someone's parks and
join up, it's super normal. Yeah.
Well,
what's crazy is that like if I was,
if I took out a pill bottle and put a
pill in my hand and popped it in my mouth,
if I like, nobody even goes, what's that?
Oh, I think they do. It could be anything.
Oh, I do. I see somebody take a pill. My,
what's going on, dude? He trippin
you up to man stranger. If I
see a dot dude, pop a pill,
we would make eye contact. I very
well might say, what's the pill man?
I'm nosy. Meanwhile, it's funny, people
get judgy about joints, but it's like, oh,
how about drink right in front of you,
right?
Antidepressants and a painkiller and
an anti. He was an inside the medicine,
but they'll give you a
funny look for smoking.
A joint self-medicating after
meditating. You know what I mean? Yeah.
But the joint,
the problem is if you went now other
people have to smell it and some people
think about like secondhand smoke and
they think you're in some your way.
You're making them smell this thing that
you're doing. You see what I'm saying?
Yeah. I guess smelling. Yeah. It's
like someone with a big stinky cigar.
There's sitting right next to you
at a bar. You'd be like, oh Jesus,
this guy is stinky ass
cigar or cigarettes.
So you smoked cigarettes so you
don't realize how vital they are.
But when someone else who
doesn't smoke cigarettes,
Nelson like I had to be with Stan
hope we were in a closed room.
We were talking about something.
Then he just sparks up.
We're in the comedy store bar, the little
comedians bar. I had to stand outside.
I'm like, dude, you just smoked
three cigarettes in five minutes.
I got to go outside.
There's no air left in this room
and just all cigarette smoke.
You don't even think about
it because it's super normal.
I love it. How much do you smoke? Now?
I'm cutting back a little bit.
I'm gonna pack a day a little bit less.
Little bit less. We're getting there.
I really am. I'm doing some work.
I just got some,
uh,
I just got this DVD set that's supposed
to like hypnotize the magic out of it.
It's supposed to make you realize what
like a terrible person you are for
smoking cigarettes.
Well, you know, terrible
person. You're just being silly.
Yeah, I was tortured. You're
just like, I know that it's bad.
It's an interesting feeling though.
I've smoked one of your cigarettes before.
It gives you like a little head rush.
Like it's good to do right before
a show worth nine. Yeah. I mean,
I don't think you should do it because if
you do it, you'll get addicted and you,
you'll swap a lot of them.
But if you're the type of person that
gets smoke one cigarette and then go do
something, I think it has a, it's
been kind of proven that nicotine,
you actually wouldn't have to smoke,
just take nicotine gum,
but that nicotine has a cognitive benefit,
but it's actually like a nootropic.
I can't imagine writing or performing
without nicotine. That part's weird.
Wow. That's crazy. You can go without
anything else. But that, that part's guys,
that's crazy. They
started on it. You know,
it sucks where I'm from and young sound,
I'm not making lazy excuses,
but where I'm from,
tons of people smoked,
everybody smoked and my parents smoked
and you know they both quit now.
But when I was growing up it was like my,
I thought my dad was cool as hell.
This cool Italian guy. What uptone and
he'd light up a cigarette all cool.
Like a real Italian guy with a Zippo
and the pack of Marlboro Lights and he
looked cool and it in my favorite movie
was good my whole life and everybody
mixed smoking look cool on that.
Real Weird of Robert Deniro joke has she?
Everybody's fucking smoking as
selling cigarettes, eaten pasta block,
taking a lobster out of the ice.
Everything looks better in that will.
It is crazy that cigarettes are thought
of as a cool thing and it's also,
there's a thing where you
know that it's bad for you.
You're doing it any way
because you don't give a fuck.
It is, it's definitely the
weirdest, stupidest thing that I do.
Like, I've never even
tried cocaine, not once,
which I think is almost like unheard of
for somebody doing standup in a life for
10 years. I've never tried it
either. Really? Nope. Yeah.
But meanwhile I, and the reason why I
don't try it is because I don't, you know,
I don't want to know.
Well, I did a, um, a tea once,
it's called Mata de Coco.
It's a tea that you make
with coca leaves and um,
it's not, it's like a super mild
tea. Like, you know, the coca leaves,
they chew them and it gives him energy
almost like, like a coffee thing.
But I didn't like the feeling,
I couldn't shut the fuck up.
I was talking too much.
I was just feeling like really? And that
was just from that, I was like, God,
what would I be like on coke?
Yeah. But anyway, so yeah, I think
that has a lot to do with it.
Like makes shitty environment coming up.
And now that I'm used to doing
everything with that Crotch,
like it's sort of just trying to like
slowly retrain the brain and slowly create
new habits and figure it all out.
But definitely going to quit here.
So let's start smiling.
More proud.
Good move. Yeah. I mean,
it's just so bad for your health
and you don't want to die young man,
and you don't want to like have a
slow death either. The worst thing is,
oh shit. That's it ladies and
gentlemen. And on that note,
we're going to wrap this bitch
up and bringing it on down.
I see the ground outside the window.
Yep.
No chem trails again. I keep waiting.
All right folks. We'll see you.
Thanks.
Bye.